[Music]
I'm the one
oh girl if you want to tell that story
live oh we are people have been waiting
for this moment for a while they're
wondering what announcement's gonna be
made they're wondering what is going on
uh the beginning of our interaction me
talking about you and let me just set
the tone here before we get into it we
got a special guest in the house you're
here because you want to find out what
this guy his name is Stephen Crowder you
know who he is uh number one
conservative late night comedy show uh
six million Subs billions of views
online he's loved and hated which is why
he does so well not afraid of uh facing
anybody uh arguably one of the most
talented guys out there some would say
the most talented voice on the
conservative side
um
I will say a couple things you know when
uh when when Steven's gonna be on uh uh
and I don't want you to get
uncomfortable about this one guy said be
careful if you're talking to him he may
record the conversation
this is being recorded I had no idea
a little professional I come in your own
suits like I don't know let's just go
live live
not me a minute ago school teacher was
doing cocaine a minute ago here but and
then the other part here's the other
part here's a I've been in business for
a long time and I was asking this from
Rob I said I gotta ask this on the live
because I talked about on the video uh
uh and maybe because there's levels to
success you got to make it to certain
levels of success I said Rob how what do
I need to do to be able to predict a
future family emergency right to say a
week ago and hey we have a family or
interest that came up on Tuesday which
by the way to be fair to you Matt Walsh
was supposed to be on Wednesday and he
also just had a family emergency yeah
when we announced you're going to be out
so I don't know what's going on you're a
family emergency yeah so but but here's
the part here's the part to know so
everybody you have a family emergency
yeah so okay so so
Stephen and I you and I got on a call
with uh Greg AKA how dare you Gerald
Paul yeah
it's basic [__] white guy names they're
impossible mine's like an old school
name it's not even basic anymore you
were professional enough to reach out we
got on the phone and when I got on the
call I had no idea what direction the
call was gonna go ended up being an
incredible call with you uh obviously
I've seen you uh uh you know whether
anybody says anything about you you're
one the best in the world in the
conservative side some would say you are
the best in the world well thank you and
the the back and forth with daily wire
uh for people that follow daily wires
content everyone knows what Ben has done
over the years yeah uh everyone knows
what Candace has done everyone knows
what those guys have done even Matt
Walsh with what is a woman documentary
which I thought it was you know he
crushed of what he's got going on and uh
you know so everyone kind of got it and
said wait a minute what is going on with
these two guys and then boom you were
supposed to be on we had a great comment
and here we are with you we all have
some announcements to make today yeah
yeah and I appreciate it yeah what
happened was uh there's a whole thing
you know I don't really do a lot of
press a lot of people don't sort of
realize that like it's very very rare
yeah if I want to say something I'll say
it on my show and I'm kind of reclusive
actually I'm actually surprisingly shy
and so I just end up talking more when
I'm around people thanks is that she
turns away
the way this started off like people are
like what that's unprofessional he
opened a can how dare that's it with you
in these cans uh so um yeah so you don't
do a lot of press I know I don't do a
lot I don't do a lot of press uh just
because I don't really like it so much
like I'm not I'm a pretty private guy uh
if you look at my like social media I've
never taken pictures of my food you know
um I never take pictures of my my family
or my children I keep that close to the
vest because I think it's a choice they
have to make uh and uh I come at this
from you know I came came in as an actor
and a stand-up comic and an Entertainer
first and then just after getting beat
in the face by you know a leftist
industry being banned as a comedian from
clubs and from colleges just kind of
started letting my freak flag fly back
in 2009 when there really what there
wasn't there were no conservatives on
YouTube that didn't exist
um so yeah as far as the announcements
uh we're pretty excited well yeah I'm a
lot I'm glad you're allowed to say
certain things so yes
so mug Club is officially which was my
camera here is that is that all right if
I had a can to open I'd make it a little
wait the one on the left the one on the
left one on the right uh March 20th
March 20th is when it's coming back
Daily Show lived with credit.com what
we're doing is uh it's it's ten dollars
less than it was before and we're about
doubling the content so uh we'll be
doing a show on Friday we have some I
don't know which people we can announce
but we have we've got a few people we're
still as you know working out all the
details yeah so there's some stuff we
still have to kind of finalize but a lot
of really exciting things yeah and the
reason for that too is you know um we
have tentative agreements with some
people and then some concrete agreements
with other people is signing uh
Equitable contracts that are transparent
that hopefully set a new standard you
know in in this industry I mean this is
something I've been doing for a long
time I know what a contract looks like
you know what a term sheet looks like
um and uh I in my opinion we talked
about this on on the phone call
sure you can make more short term if you
kind of just scrape every dollar you can
but long term that doesn't really work
the best business deal is one where
everyone benefits everyone is happy
because why was special with Talent like
how often have you heard of people
whether it's Dave Chappelle uh or
whether you know South Park in the
episode with the Mohammed issues you
can't keep people who don't want to be
there you know so you have to frame it
in a way where they're happy where they
benefit and you benefit and people you
want to work with so March 20th uh March
20th we're coming back we're coming like
a bat out of hell yeah it's always you
know it's you always get nervous see you
don't seem that way he knows like I
always get nervous before every single
show I had horrible stage fright before
I got up and would do stand up I used to
I used to think it was less embarrassing
when I would tell the stories like
before my just for last audition I went
backstage and I threw up but the truth
is I wouldn't throw up I would just I
would have explosive poops yes but I
thought it was more masculine yeah
I'm like I have a sensitive tummy
so I need to run into the bathroom I
need some Tums yeah exactly yeah not a
good look probably this guy after all
that cocaine right
it's hard for you to shed that but you
still get nervous when you do shows is
that what you're saying still even a
show like this you're nervous right here
and then when did the nerves go away
never so you're nervous right now I'm
nervous right now don't do what you
typically do before a show right now
please yeah well you know what it is is
uh I've always told this to to Gerald
and to everyone else who also works
there
um is every single time you do a show I
say assume that that is a 100 new
audience and you sort of learn this when
you're coming up through stand up uh
because you'll be doing like six shows
you know Thursday Two Friday two
Saturday two and you can do really
really well three and then you bomb
because you get a little overconfident
yeah that is a new group of people who
are not familiar with you haven't built
any momentum with them right so I always
want to make sure that people are
getting their money's worth you know
there's there's so much content out
there and sometimes we work in an
industry where yeah it's about Investors
or it's about advertising those are all
fine too uh but I think True North
should always be the the audience and
what it is that they want and how you
most benefit them and long term if you
do that I think you'll end up doing well
but uh you know I'm not really a
business guy I'm not like you I was
looking when we were doing research here
I always prepare this guy is like he's
like the Monopoly guy
this guy is like crazy wealthy
you want to say a few words for yourself
but you know it's crazy that you're
saying the nervous thing because Tyson
also talked about that you know some of
the best athletes talked about that yeah
were prior to it and it it is a quality
of a great one it's not like uh uh you
know some people are a little bit more
calmer when they go in you know you see
remember like Fedor used to fight Pride
you go and they're like this guy looks
like his he's about to take a nap he
would bring it all the way down and Kobe
would go very ice-like and that was his
style but there are some that's the
other way around either way you ended up
you know remember George Saint Pierre
when he when we had him six months ago
he would get so nervous I was always
afraid of my opponents yes
I'm gonna stand up too and I've you know
I've done two specials I've been on
Kevin Hart special I I think if you
don't have that like but some guys don't
they don't have like zero I think you I
think that I think they're lying he's
right if some don't have it no they
don't care they don't care they're those
guys that don't get nervous for a big
audience I don't know I've been around
him I mean good example is like Chuck
Liddell when he would fight uh John
Halcomb he said he just doesn't get
nervous yeah he just doesn't get nervous
um but I've always been uh that way yeah
do you get nervous ever like you see you
speak on massive stages you don't get
nervous on podcasts I already know that
but even when you go on stage when
you're speaking in front of big
audiences I I don't know I don't know if
I do at this phase uh uh I don't know if
I do at this phase so that settles it I
guess he's not a great yeah
Mr mediocre 100 millionaire over here
but but I would tell you there are
certain uh times you made depending on
what the climate is but I want to go
back to your announcements so my club is
coming back that's exciting uh when we
shared a video today the tweet all this
everybody was like when is it coming
March 20th yeah so people are dying for
that the fact that that's coming back
that's big news we the question I want
to ask from you is can I specify one
thing because we had you know so many
people who signed up at mugclub
forever.com and I know some people have
signed up and so then we you know we had
this contract up and so we left so we
want to make sure they're not
shortchanged so if you have signed up at
mugclub forever.com check your spam
folder tomorrow you're going to get a
code to pre-order and get a bunch of of
uh free time and free months to honor
kind of what you left General do we have
a link to put down their in chat in
description to people can go to is there
a link or mud clubforever.com okay let's
put that in the chat and description and
comment Rob all three so they can get it
and maybe every 30 minutes just drop it
in there so they can get it as well yeah
like Ron Popeil
[Laughter]
so so let's let's go back to this here's
here's kind of one I want what I want to
do uh with the audience and some of the
question that maybe I have with the
whole thing with daily wiring yourself
and and you know uh uh prior to going
into some of the we'll talk about issues
we'll talk about current events we'll
talk about some of that stuff but daily
wire so the question that kept coming up
uh uh Stephen was you know well you know
uh whether it's Candace came out and
said you know I wanted to find out what
he had to say or Ben Shapiro came well
this is how a negotiation works if you
don't like it you go back and forth
let's go how many times did you guys go
back and forth until it was like okay
you know you did a video you didn't
mention the company's name everybody's
trying to kind of guess who it is but
most people kind of knew it was daily
wire they were talking about and then
they came out Jeremy went through the
contract you know one by one by one and
then you responded then there's the
recording then there's this and then it
was like Hey Candace comes out Jordan
Peterson tweet delete all the stuff
that's going on right but the question
is the world's biggest high school I get
it but yeah question for me is how many
conversations did you guys have up until
the point where it's like we're not
doing this yeah so I mean and to rehash
like all that stuff because yeah I think
people now kind of know like you make
your decision and I love Jordan Peterson
like Andrew like I'm still friends with
a lot of people over there
um the issue there was there was never
look the issue I always had was and I
said take me off the table because it
wasn't going to be a fit the issue was
with other people the primary issue you
never heard me talk about money and I
know as a business guy there's probably
like like nails on a chalkboard but it's
uh you know you can't penalize people
you can't put on 110 penalties on behalf
of big Tech literally 110 penalties
um but primarily if you have other kids
who are coming up like you can't punish
conservative content creators on behalf
of big Tech saying not only do you have
to be there you have to be monetized
which you know on YouTube right that's a
very different set of guidelines is
basically don't say anything offensive
ever all I can say is is uh there was
never anything that we went over that
involved that being eliminated like that
was the sticking point like yeah okay
get rid of that no that that doesn't
happen and so we decided okay we're
going to go uh on our way and do it
um now we're focusing on what it is that
we can do what it is that we can change
and bringing in other people so from the
beginning of the conversation series
until this was made is that like five
weeks it's two months three months is
there like uh months okay good so it's
not like it was a because some people
are thinking hey we're out of here we're
done first offered I can't believe
you're doing this I'm blasting your
public okay so that's good to know
that's between you and them you guys can
you know that's a conversation between
you and the people you were working with
sure here's the other question the issue
is is when you don't see eye down like
look take it off the take me away yeah
the issue is the punishment on behalf of
big Tech or the issues like you know
I've been demonetized for this long yep
that can be red line and changed wasn't
so that's the issue it's like that was
the issue as far as okay this isn't
going to happen because of the big Tech
penalties and I understand it too by the
way look when you're in a war
and I mean that we are an ideological
war uh we really are we are at a
potential Tipping Point in this country
you need different kinds of people you
need different battalions and I get it
that some people want to work within the
platforms uh in order to change the
platforms well no one understands that
more than me because I've been there
since you know before there was
monetization actually my brother was one
of the first uh YouTube partners I think
in 2000
seven 2008 whenever they started it uh
but the issue was when the platform no
longer allows you to speak truth I'm not
looking to be removed from YouTube I've
talked about that uh and the people who
we've signed we want nothing to do with
whether they are on YouTube or not as
far as I'm concerned that's blood money
like I would and I don't mean it's blood
Money blood but I mean I don't want to
have to influence someone to play ball
with YouTube or Facebook or tell them
not to if that's what they choose to do
the issue is when you have a platform
like YouTube like Facebook that says you
know what you can't say uh for example
that there's myocarditis with young
people right or there could be potential
adverse effects of the MRNA injection
with young people when they say you
can't say that we're going to suspend
you you are now no longer able to speak
truth so we'll use those platforms as
long as they're available provided that
we're allowed to speak the truth but
when we get to the point and we've had
these conversations where we're like
well you want to quote the CDC and the
flu death today he's like well you still
want you want to be suspended for
another two weeks or hey do you want to
have Carrie Lake who's currently running
for governor it's like well you know
we're going to be suspended and miss the
election stream that night and we just
decided to let the cards fall where they
may it's it's reached that point
unfortunately yeah so that's so the so
the okay so I understand that so then
the question will be the following is it
fair to say that the uh like if you were
to announce if you were to say right now
who are the top I don't know five six
seven uh conservative media companies
out there you got Fox you got daily wire
who else would you put out there would
you put Blaze as one of them as an
option
I don't know I don't have access to
their financials it's a question I
couldn't answer so let's put aside the
financials let's say influence I guess
let's just measure it by influence that
you and I can see who would you put as
like Prager you I'm Prager using well
that's part of daily wire now I'm
talking more like CNN MSNBC you know you
got it you know whoever they have on the
other side or [__] eyeballs you're
talking views you're talking cloud yeah
I'm talking about like if I say who are
the biggest podcasters today not
political at all okay you got Rogan you
got you know impulsive you got you know
whoever you know call her that you know
all these things that you see not
necessarily political you can say these
are the most influential ones right
within the conservative side who would
you say are the top five most
influential media companies today
I mean this is on there yeah you name
them I mean if people consider them you
know conservative you'd have Fox on
there you'd have daily wire on there um
you know you probably have like a red
State Town Hall Salem it's a big one
okay yeah um very familiar with them uh
I I don't know I mean krlas with Salem
right krlies with Salem kkles they do
they have like red State Town Hall a lot
of radio stations so they're really big
uh you know why I'm asking a question
I'm asking a question because I don't
know if there's enough of them that's
what I'm asking I think yeah that's the
point yeah so if there isn't enough of
them so you guys if I can get this uh if
I can get it right you're planning on
building a conservative media platform
recruiting other talent to come in under
your umbrella yeah to put that's what
you're trying to do yeah but it's a
different approach yeah and perfect this
is why it's different is um I don't need
to do it right so this is so uh for and
Ben I've known for a very long time I
think Ben is the best at what he does
certainly among them you'd have like
Mark Levin's up there of course at one
point Rush Limbaugh
um but Ben didn't do that until you know
daily wire happened before that he was
he was working other places like
Breitbart
um the issue is
when all these companies do it the same
the same way right it's the same it's
people talking about news and that's
fine but at a certain point you have to
ask if it's by Design now here's the
thing it's because these companies need
people to do that in order to and look I
can tell you this when I was uh working
at Fox News for like four and a half
years
changed my mind when it was pitched to
every major publisher I've talked about
this it was pitched as a segment at Fox
News and people said that will never
work so it will never work people want
four or five minutes they want it snappy
right they want you in a quadrant view
one time I think it was on with Lanny
Davis or might have been Doug shown on
Fox news they had this in this quadrant
View and I was always getting in trouble
I'd always get called into the second
floor but we're shocking we're in the
same room
and they have us on these like these
quadrant views I'm like why is he doing
I'm right I'm right there here I am and
so at the end of the segment I think it
was Lanny Davis I was like Hey Lanny
high five and I reached into his
quadrant so and they were like you know
you can't do that because people like it
to seem really International I was like
I don't really know if that's what
people necessarily want and so I say you
know what I'm going to go out and do a
comedy show which they said
conservatives don't really like comedy
this way at that point in time they said
uh you can't do what you're gonna sit
down with random people to have
conversations for an hour unedited two
hours I said yeah I remember when I
pitched it as a book although at that
point the term social justice Warrior
didn't exist or triggered so the term I
used was uh American Idiot because Green
Day was big at this point in time and I
separated between them and sort of the
modern leftist and they said no no the
only thing we can sell to conservatives
is the Doomsday books and it's not a bad
book but the Obama blueprint was a
really big book at that time they said
you have anything like this and I said
well that's not me so I don't need to do
like we can do them and do our show
right matter of fact we'd be more
profitable just doing that but providing
a platform for people who aren't looking
to make it big in the conservative space
but particularly people you'll see with
the people who we sign and the names of
someone who's done comedy
um you're Adam and you're very sorry I
almost said uh said Adam uh people who
can be who they are and reach a
different reach a different group of
people like there's a reason too like
the conservative demographic is it's
quite literally dying off unfortunately
and uh it's very lucrative to sell them
certain kinds of of messaging certain
kinds of content I don't mean immoral
but when people are precluded from
reaching them there are a lot of people
out there like me like Joe like our
audience the average viewer is a
20-something 30 year old uh college
educated male they're not tuning in to
Fox News they're not tuning into a lot
of you know AM radio but they are tuning
into what we do because it's it's a
comedy show and I don't mean a comedian
who does a show and you know that's
right like a lot of comedians they'll
host podcasts it's not a comedy show
exactly this is an entertainment show
and the reason we had to go and do it on
our own was it's never going to work and
then every time you sit at that side of
the table whether it's Fox whether
whoever it is they go can we change it
so that you you can fit into the box
this way because that's our box and we
want to do the opposite and we don't
have to do it we can say what's your box
what is it that you are let's give you
the opportunity to let your freak flag
fly so I want to go on this I want to go
a little bit more on this but I want to
go quickly the question I want to ask
you in a minute here is you're right you
don't have to do it but you are a voice
you do have a massive following and
there is a niche there is an emptiness
that we need somebody to do great if
you're going to do it and what's the
structure going to be different and then
you made a comment about Fox you said
some would call Fox a conservative
that's that some would take that as a
dig but I want to come back to this here
in a second
let me just do it quick today's sponsor
today's sponsor today's sponsor is
goldco okay let me tell you why goldco
I've been in the financial industry for
nearly uh 22 years now and I've been
able to invest into a lot of different
things stock spons mutual funds real
estate all this stuff we have no idea
what's going to be happening with the
economy inflation interest rates when it
comes down to a small percentage of your
money to hedge against
inflation and crisis taking place gold
may be a good investment for you we
looked at goldco we looked at a lot of
different folks we talked to people that
work with these guys we like what they
have to do I myself like to do business
with companies like this if you want to
get into the gold uh investment yourself
give these guys a call they're a
six-time Inc 5000 winner 2022 company of
the year with thousands of five star
reviews and I've helped people like you
and me place over a billion dollars in
gold and silver by a team of yours could
get up to ten thousand dollars in free
silver and a free one ounce silver
Ronald Reagan coin with a qualified
order column
855-594-2758-855-594-2758 or go to
goldco.com forward slash pbdgoldco.com
forward slash pbd Rob let's put the link
below so let me go back that's a lot of
free silver are you serious yes yeah yes
you want some of that I would love
someone
a person who loves gold
is that a surprise
in your house you have like those lions
that are like fountains right that kind
of stuff dude you know what I married a
white girl from Texas
because white girls from
don't love status symbols they don't
like lions like that there are some
places though in Texas I've been to
those places where you see Lions but
they're white they're white yes
white or you know white lines and how
yeah by the way first time I moved to uh
uh uh Dallas and I'm in Highland Park
we're having dinner at one of the
restaurants there and the lady says you
know what Dallas is one of the most vain
cities in the world yes
you want to do any kind of surgery
augmentation this Botox this may be the
number one city for doing any kind of
cosmetic surgery that's Dallas
specifically Highland Park by the way
yeah you end up leaving there looking
like Jennifer Coolidge
that's a MILF right there well I don't
know we're using that term loosely don't
be
disrespectedly just like the skin
don't have to do the neck if you're
doing your yeah it's stiffler's Mom
respect yes yeah yeah by the way I I was
friends oh come on that's not you're
bringing it up to the audience I look
like it that's not no no no no
pull her up from White Lotus then you'll
get a really good view of what she looks
like now so so let's go back to it so
Stephen what's so the question is one
you don't need to do it but you're
choosing to do it so if you're
recruiting talent and you know now know
what daily wires contract is because
you've gone directly with them yeah you
now know what Fox's contract is you now
know what Blake's contract is you you
kind of got experience of the top guys
in the marketplace how they do so that
kind of gives you an edge to say we
don't want to do it this way we don't
want to do it that way here's what we're
going to do so my open-ended question
for you will be the following assume a
lot of people that love your stuff are
watching this and their talent they may
want to come and run with you okay and
they may want to say okay Stephen let's
come wrong with you here's what we want
to do what are some things a talent is
gonna get from teaming up with you that
they may not get at other places well
here's the deal it's uh and he's
obviously so Gerald has seen several
conversations like this recently yes
uh but I will say this you know having
experience with okay with stand-up it's
a perfect example when you're doing
standard right when you start out you're
starting doing whatever it was like when
I was you're middling you know doing I'm
sorry when you're on the road you're
being paid you're getting a few hundred
dollars to Middle to write the feature
and then if you're a headliner you know
you might get 1500 for the whole weekend
and then you reach a certain point where
you're doing these venues they give you
a minimum guarantee okay so this is not
Reinventing the wheel the minimum
guarantee doesn't matter if your your
aunt your uncle and your dad show up
right or you say you know what lower
that guarantee and I'll take a higher
percentage of the gate uh so when I do
live shows I say like give me basically
the closest you can to no guarantee and
the highest percentage of the gate
that's all it is it's a sliding scale
you always need to have upside to be
incentive yeah incentivized and
especially when they're content creators
you always need to have some ownership
and autonomy in the realm of Comedy
um or some people want more of a
guarantee so this side is more of an
employee this side is basically you're
doing a revenue split and depending what
it is that you want or need if it's
production if it's editing if it's
social media that changes the percentage
you can bet on yourself get a higher
percentage of the gate or we also have
options where there's a higher minimum
guarantee it's not Reinventing it this
is how it works in the entertainment
industry the only place it doesn't work
that way is in you know that I've
experienced is in the right wing uh the
right-wing media sphere it's it's very
bizarre it's an anomaly
wow so so it's interesting what you're
saying if I'm reading this correctly
I've ran a insurance company now for you
know 13 years going on 14 years and I've
been in the insurance industry for 20
years I start off with Morgan Stanley
Morgan Stanley gave me a salary plus
commission I made the least money with
Morgan Stanley Dean with her because
they gave me a salary so my commission
was like this then I want to trans
transgave me a commission like this with
zero salary I love I said trans gave me
this yeah someone's friends
Kobe right was like he was like he's
like Kobe you know he would be ice cold
like did he just say that yeah
you have to have a degree to understand
the last joke he just gave but if
there's levels to this this guy's a
little too brilliant for I don't think
you need a degree to understand what
assuming room temperature means yeah go
ahead so here go back going back to the
question so is Transamerica to be exact
don't stupid again oh you like that
buddy
is this what you want me to do right
so they pay commission then we go we
start our own company and same thing
okay it's commission based here's how it
works go do your thing the upside is Big
you can make tens of millions but at the
same time you got to do the work you got
to go out there you got to do this you
got to do that right this attracts a
certain set of talents where your skill
set as an operator has to be being a
king maker okay where a person like a
daily wire or a fox their model isn't
necessarily to be a king maker they
attract Kings meaning daily wire didn't
Bill Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson is
a king they recruited a king that went
and joined daily wire right Fox News
didn't build back didn't build you
didn't build Tucker didn't build
O'Reilly didn't build a lot of these
guys now some may say well they
certainly didn't build me yeah I was I
would say I had great people at five I
was constantly like you can't say that
I'd be like what could you put on a
jacket I'm like wow
me to change and it just wasn't the
right thing I was 21. but that but
that's the point though so is your plan
to kind of whoever comes and joins you
and runs with you guys that you're gonna
share with them the tricks to the game
that worked for you so it's almost like
and I don't know if you follow
basketball or sports or not where the
Golden State Warriors were like yeah
we're not gonna go put a super team
together bring this guy bring that guy
let's draft let's bring in Steph Curry
let's bring in clay let's bring in
Draymond let's build these guys up and
boom let's win four championships yeah
it's your plan to recruit more Greenies
no are you guys also willing to pay the
5 10 million dollars to recruit some big
names well I would say actually like for
example with daily Wire yeah or even
like the blaze yeah um Jordan Peterson's
an exception he really is an exceptional
it's very recent that they brought in
someone like him because yeah he is a
king he's an unbelievably talented uh
and has an unbelievable audience I mean
if you go back to Fox News right you're
going back a while like Sean Hannity
after 9 11 I think he was out of Atlanta
then he became nationally syndicated
they brought him and Bill O'Reilly was
Inside Edition Beck before that had a
huge radio show and he was on I think
was HLN so what they would do is bring
in people who were kind of that middle
tier and then they were more of a
platform to kind of be a springboard but
what you see with a lot of them is when
they leave Fox uh their podcasts don't
really work that well right because this
isn't just sort of a passive viewership
yeah I mean there's some some folks yeah
that's hard but listen well because you
don't have people telling you hey this
is who you want to watch people are
tuning into you because you're
interested yeah not because you have you
know a giant train Cam and a crotch
camera with a see-through desk did you
shave your legs Stephen did you do this
fix your hair do the makeup I just went
the way God made one of the things that
the audience is watching this I was very
impressed to see he came with a makeup
girl that did his makeup for 45 minutes
before it was very impressive yeah you
know the hair somebody was fixing your
hair in the background you thought the
syringes were for blackness
amazing
so so going back to that I had a couple
guys here I'm I'm talking to uh uh uh
anyway some of the guys from Fox News
and they said to me let me tell you this
is Murdoch but let me tell you the magic
behind Roger rails I said what's that he
was a king maker okay I said tell me
more he says he knew how to get somebody
to poke him here push him here challenge
him here show him this take this angle
think about doing this think about
showing the place he was a king maker so
you know how to do that yeah is your
game plan to go from being a talent to
want to be a king maker that's a long
term here's here's the thing long term
right you know what I'm asking yeah long
term there's no bench like so I said
this a long time ago where I I would
love to retire and I don't mean
necessarily be uh like Les P Diddy like
more Suge Knight like dangling Vanilla
Ice outside of a balcony you know where
if I want to move uh
death row I saw a guy today walking with
a Death Row Records like shirt yeah I
want to say hey death row but then I
don't really know the city that well he
could be like shut up and shoot me no
idea
um so uh yeah so I would like I would
love to retire and eventually produce
content more but there's there really
can be no next show like mine you know
later with Crowder unless there's an
environment where it can exist and if
you have to be in an environment where
you have to play ball with these you
know these big Tech effectively I mean
you could say do a trip opoly really
you're really talking about three
companies it can't happen it can't
happen there cannot be a show I mean
Gerald and I talk about this all the
time I can't imagine what our show would
look like if we had to be uh Advertiser
friendly let alone never be suspended on
YouTube like we just decided to forego
the money and by the way I don't really
care so much about the revenue on
YouTube we've talked about this but once
we were demonetizing that was a Vox
apocalypse
um they stopped counting our subscribers
so the number would be about 12 to 15
million subscribers in the main Channel
and what we had was for years I was
monetized uh the channel we were gaining
between 120 to 250 000 subscribers every
single month I think our lowest month in
that period was 80 and our highest might
have been close to like 300. then we
worked in a month in a month yeah every
and every month was over 100 something
thousand the average was 130 something
like that like that yeah then we were
demonetized yeah the Vox apocalypse
because they couldn't remove us because
we didn't violate any policies yeah
right you see Susan wojcicki who was
talking at the recode conference saying
like sorry it's not really hate speech
but we'll create a new rule of
borderline content so the second word
you monetized boom we were down to 10
000 at most thirty thousand subscribers
a month because you can't find us in
browse if you search my name and the
title of the video you'll find something
else someone screwed up at Google
YouTube and accidentally remonetized
this was it for like four months three
or four months we're like What boom 130
to 200 000 average per month again
demonetized down to 10 or 30. and here's
the reason why is because it's right
it's a finances game of course YouTube
wants to migrate people toward
Advertiser content and then of course
they want you to play ball and say by
the way you need to be Advertiser
friendly don't talk about the trans
thing don't talk about the election
don't talk about the vaccines and then
when you have conservatives saying hey
you know what we want to make sure we
keep making this revenue from YouTube
think about that when people say and I
used to be a Libertarian you know until
I I grew out of it and I would still be
considered more libertarian than most
conservatives but it's not a free it's
it's not about a private company doing
what they want when these people enjoy
benefits uh both both as far as policy
as far as taxes from the government
section 230 right when they're protected
they use the law when it's convenient
and then they violate the law when it's
not convenient and they use that to
engineer the kind of content not only
that you see but that is on there so
yeah we kind of said okay we'll we'll
decide like rather than 12 15 million
but not being able to discuss anything
we'll have to build it the hard way it
is a very very difficult slog that's
what bothered me was the lack of access
to new people right if you have a
storefront that's always boarded up it's
really hard to generate new customers
it's the same thing it's hard to
generate new viewers the viewership that
we have
on the show is almost 100 from people
who bookmark it and check it every day
wow so the suggestions for you is not
that high I think it was less than two
percent let
suggestions is less than two percent
browse search suggested they were in
single digits all of them yeah holy sh
they probably suggest people watch
something else other than our show you
you know you know what you know what is
well yeah that's gonna be the thumbnail
with that yeah I mean come on who's not
watching
but but by the way so so going back to
that I bet if if you were to show the
data on what happened with dates that
would be an interesting thing to look we
could probably hey someone watched it we
could probably send them to you right
now oh if you have your guy reach out we
could send you at least the before and
after I would love to see that data to
just show it if you can I don't know who
in your communication with if you want
to send them a I think he had an email
earlier setting up some of the tech
stuff those guys might Gerald do you
have your phone with you yeah I do they
can text it to me too if I if I okay if
you wanna text it to me I can get it up
on the screen fantastic so let me let me
go to the next question which is all
within the same topic
um
so there's a difference when I went from
being an employee to a salesperson it
sucked because it had a warm salary now
I don't oh my God it was so annoying
okay yeah then you go from salesperson
you learn how to close then you become a
sales leader
you're teaching other people how to
learn how to sell let me tell you it's
very annoying yeah very annoying you
have to have to pay so how do you not
understand use this script if I can do
this they couldn't do it all right so
you got to be patient because it takes a
long time so then I went from being a
sales leader to seal I sucked as a seal
so I go in I'm like I have to find out
what it is being a business owner is
different than a CEO right so for you do
you really as a as a talent like I I
used to sit there and watch a lot of the
guys I was in business with who were
very very good these people I respected
up till today I respect for what they
built why did they never go start their
own companies and I would ask them
you're very good why didn't you go start
your own company deal with compliance
deal with all that stuff why don't you
just why don't you stay put he says I
don't want that life yeah so Talent
think about O'Reilly think about Hannity
think about Tucker think about you know
I can give you a bunch of these names
think about on the other side Cuomo
tamper madow Cooper think about all of
these guys why did they never go and say
I want to start my own company okay and
then let's go on the podcast side
because you may say what's a different
reading the teleprompter you know and
today and you see their eyes going like
this the entire time okay he's reading
the teleprompter okay a lot of people
this is hard what you do is very hard to
keep people's attention a hundred
thousand people's attention you did one
for 16 hours I don't know what 16 hours
yeah 16 hour life that's ridiculous yeah
so do you really as a
creative want to go into dealing with
talent and telling them and giving them
tips on how to build and manage uh
don't you think I'm not going to tell
them and here's the thing that's
different yeah it is different uh well
that's also why he's CEO yeah no it's
been a company I've been running a
company for a very long time you have
20-something employees that's why I've
owned Lottery
like like uh Ben Shapiro and Jeremy
where Ben is the talent and Jeremy's
more like the day-to-day CEO I don't
know what their inner workings are well
based on what I've heard I don't either
by the way just so you know a lot of
people because they had money guys you
know we don't have that that's the
differences we don't have like we that's
one thing too we've never taken a dime
of seed money we've always made it back
literally within the first quarter
explain why that's important the fact
that what is the difference if they do
because some people may say well you
know I know you're saying since Stephen
but the fact that Ben and Jeremy and
those guys have money from those oil
guys that I think is like the fracking
guys that got the three and a half
billion dollars and they're fun and
getting here is 50 million 100 million
300 million whatever they're doing so
they can go get the bigger guys right
what's wrong with that what is no
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with it well I should say this we do
have technically seed money it's you
it's mug club right we're not funded by
a foreign caliphate like The Young Turks
you know in some way and I'm partially
joking yeah uh we don't have you know
oil bearing money we have uh people
that's it we don't have a lot of
sponsors either and by the way 100 of
the sponsors wanted to come because we
always make sure that they get more
value than they pay for you know in this
you know this in this industry right
there's a lot of paying for views and
downloads that don't really happen yep
so for us we go to them in the way we've
con uh structured contracts is okay if
you don't you know if you if you don't
like what we do because we don't do
libraries we do these really weird
commercials sometimes that get a little
get a little off the off the beam so if
you don't like it just don't just don't
pay for it and like we we don't need to
do this we think you're gonna like it
100 of the time they do but you have to
coach those people creatively right it
used to be for example Gerald remembers
this I was I would be yelling on the
phone with billionaires I'd be like no
you don't know what you're talking about
where I had people come in when I had I
think half a million subscribers they
said you know free is the enemy of
Premium because at that point we had
built a lot of subscribers I said well
you don't understand it's free it's an
advertising venue it reaches people and
rather than tricking people into paying
you provide value added and people will
pay because they want to support you
right sometimes people go hold on a
second I'm paying and um basically the
show is out there for free and all these
sponsors are on here whether it's four
five ten you know and they go usually it
used to be at one point in time we would
pay so it would be ad-free they go what
am I paying for we've always tried to
make it really really clear and provide
value added now as far as um with
content with Talent
um I'm not going to tell them what to do
at all like they they can do what they
want because these are people who I
believe provide value added yeah and if
it doesn't work then they can go on
their merry way and take their
subscribers with them like there's
there's no exclusive completely unique
in this industry like there's nobody out
there in the conservative space that is
doing something like that and
essentially we just kind of got thrown
into this a little bit looking at all
the contracts going gosh is everybody
really doing stuff like this that just
really doesn't value the creator doesn't
value the audience the way that we think
you should and then saying we can
probably do something better and really
the better is just giving people the
opportunity to be creators the
opportunity he was never given in some
of those previous roles like hey we want
you to fit this mold for us we want you
to do it this way I'm telling creators
like look you've already started to kind
of have some success that's great that's
fantastic why don't you come and add
more value to our viewers and bring your
viewers with you add more value to them
as well yeah right so that it's just a
different model where we don't have to
and go back to your question on the
money
if it's your money versus somebody
else's money that's different right you
put a different work ethic behind every
dollar that you have that is on the line
it doesn't mean you don't value it but
also there's different interest in it
they're going to be able to dictate a
little bit more what happens if you have
other people's money yeah I have
investors in my other business I have a
wine business and of course those guys
want to see a return and if things
aren't going the way that they should go
and maybe I've made all the calls
they're going to say hey you need to
make different calls or we need a
different you in that role plus they're
usually drunk well that's why it shows
my business
it's hard to be mad in the wine business
everyone's very happy no but that's also
why Gerald you know when we were looking
at this house because For the Longest
Time right I'd get to this point well
you know with like contracts we have a
certain period you're allowed to
renegotiate often contracts are framed
but that's a very short period of time
yeah and then I'd be under the gun where
I still have always owned everything but
like ah this isn't really something that
I want to do or I don't want to do it
this way where Gerald said hey look what
if you were to do this and suggested
something similar to what we're doing
and I turned to him and I said Gerald
you know I can't do that and he said
unless I go full time because he knows
that I can't manage the sales and also
do a show every day which you know for
every hour people see it's four hours of
prep just for me I mean we have to be
right on the research we make all of our
research publicly available every single
reference it's like a bibliography uh
and we post it every single day yeah and
then we also you know we have to do
these sketches we have to we only have
punch we have photoshops we have guests
we it's very it's more of a television
show than a radio show online it's
really kind of the only one
um in that vein and that takes a lot of
work and one thing I will say is you
said that you weren't
a good did you say not a good CEO not a
good sales trainer I was not in 2014.
okay 2013. I was not a good CEO yet so
here's the thing I'm the one thing I
will say the only thing that I'm really
decent with in business is you know the
old Wayne Gretzky quote he was
mentioning basketball the Canadian in me
I'm like let's go to hockey no one knows
um
no no not that one wasted don't go where
the [__] is go where the Puck's going to
be yeah I've always been pretty good at
understanding where the puck is going to
be beyond that I have always had a
problem to struggle with uh managing
people who aren't like me and you're
probably this way right as a
self-starter sometimes like the people
I've just we've worked with for forever
like retention rate is insane with some
of these people are people who you go
hey I need to get this done they go
great and they find a way to do it I'm
results oriented there are some people
who need to be managed more and then
they'll get upset if they feel like
they're being micromanaged the people
who I've worked with really well are
people who are selfish I don't
necessarily know how to manage people
who aren't similar to me I'm a creative
type Cheryl's good at that and that's
where we're at the point now he's been
working part-time he's been on the show
we were just talking about how because
he has a great radio voice he used to
come on and talk about Theology and uh
Christian apologetics and then he would
be in that second chair uh and and he's
always run a business and we've always
wanted to make sure that we could
maintain a friendship but then it got to
a point where it's undeniable or he
would see me kind of getting just buried
like I just don't know there's no way
yeah there's no way to do it I think you
kind of alluded to it we a lot of people
think oh guys you guys have been off for
what 10 weeks or something like that
right we've been shooting
shooting like crazy writing like all
these different ideas like all of that
takes an incredible amount of time and
to run a business on top of that and to
kind of handle I mean the fires that you
have to put out in this industry
especially when you have a Target on
your back like he does it's it's just it
drains you and so we had to build some
infrastructure up with personnel and
just making sure we had people in the
right places made some new hires got the
team expanded because creators not only
want a good contract right they want to
keep their subscribers they want to know
who they are like God forbid you have to
you get to know who the people that are
paying you money are when you work for
some of these people they wanted to have
the ability to not have to deal with all
the back-end like editing and all the
other promotional stuff and people
saying can you just help me with
monetization like I know how to create
good content but I don't know all of
these different things it's kind of like
dentists you can go get a loan from A
bank right now being a dentist fresh out
of dental school they'll give you money
left and right and then everybody the
financial services people are right
behind the dentist when they're going
because they know they know their craft
they don't know how to run a business
right and make money that's what a lot
of these creators are doing but you know
you're right but they just don't know
how to run them by the way dentists
don't you know a lot of when I'm there
no Twitter I knew a girl she had just
graduated yeah she had just got now she
was like you're never going to get a
loan and she goes oh yeah the bank was
ready to give me like 150 what I'm
trying to start my business and I'm like
I've got to model this proven over seven
years most doctors have no clue what to
do not get the money they're clueless
with money you go to the house they're
making 600 Grand you think they have
everything on no nothing nothing and the
reason is because everybody thinks they
know it all because their name is what
doc so the challenge is you're a great
content creator but it's different
managing managing Talent so and I and
you said he would be doing some of this
stuff if they're wired like you it is
what it is but here's a question so
what's the what's the vision of the
company if you were to say our vision is
to dot dot dot what would the vision of
the company be well I would say it's not
my vision that's the thing it is the
vision of we in this industry you know
you always owe somebody right so my
first job ever
I don't really talk a lot about me or my
kind of history on the show but a lot of
people know this was this kid's show
Arthur on PBS uh an aardvark and he has
like a pet dog and his best friend's a
bunny you were to voice a 12 right or
something like that yeah it was a voice
of the brain who was a bear black bear I
had to do the Kwanzaa song for Christmas
the Christmas special drugs clearly
involved in this idea and uh that was
the first thing I ever did I've been
doing like extra work before that
started doing stand-up in my mid-teens
which took me kind of yeah there you go
yeah I was so bad too at the Kwanzaa rap
because I was embarrassed I was 12 years
old and I looked up Kwanzaa they're like
I had to go on there and say uh you know
and uh what's his name karenga the
Kwanzaa founder and I turned to the uh
the vocal director I said do you mean
Ron Everett I was 12. I said you mean
Ron Everett the guy who beat women with
soldering irons and poured bleach in
their mouths and it's a wanted sex
offender like we're putting this
alongside Christmas and Hanukkah and
you're saying this at 12. oh so you knew
you were going to be this time I was
fired at 13.
[Laughter]
yeah exactly well see now I'd have to
apologize that'd be black bear you're a
black bear face black bear face oh my
God but to be fair it was also really
bad where they had me do like four or
five rap verses and it was so bad I was
so embarrassed that they just added in
background singers hey come together and
now it sounds like that they're missing
four of my verses oh my God so that's
what I you know I started with doing
that uh I'm trying to go back to your
question now I've got uh for the vision
yeah so you always owe somebody yeah and
the same thing right even when you start
out and like when you're doing stand-up
it's kind of my the beauty of stand-up
comedy is you get to see these
microcosms right like I'm sure you've
had Hal gigs where you have these like I
had one guy one time try to pay me and
Coke oh have you ever had that I've had
that and I've had the guy go hey man I
don't got all the money we had to drive
to the projects for him to sell drugs
yeah get money yeah exactly okay yeah
exactly and I said no no I'm I don't do
I don't do drugs yeah he said well
you'll sell it make more money I said no
I don't do drugs like who do I who do
you want me to make the call right
so you experience these things because
you owe right and then you owe somebody
in the industry or you have to do
somebody a favor we do oh we owe
entirely mug club and that's why we have
this massive paying subscribership
because they are investing their dollar
really it's this simple they think we're
fighting for them they think most
conservatives are fighting for them and
they're disenchanted and they feel like
there aren't people who represent their
view of point you know I've been in this
industry for a long time both in the
sort of secular the entertainment side
and then the conservative side but I
didn't grow up like we didn't have Fox
News in Canada we really didn't have AM
radio occasionally I could pirate like
Rush Limbaugh
um I think like Dennis Prager uh from
Plattsburgh New York when I would be in
Montreal uh but I did grow up watching
Letterman right I did I did grew up
watching Conan uh though John Stossel
was a big influence where I found out I
was conservative before I even knew what
that was when he would do give me a
break on TGIF had him on the show
multiple times oh I love how he always
when he gets little Persnickety he like
talks to you like you're 12 like you say
that but you're investing in gold
he spoke like that to me for two hours
So Adam you say this but really you're
here on a podcast yeah but he was
brilliant he's really a sharp guy for
sure uh so that was my influence and I
sat around and I would go well there's
nothing there for me there isn't formula
when you look at at that point you have
every single late night show you have
every single comedy show an
entertainment show every single one was
left and no one on the right was really
actively trying it and they were
actively telling you that it wouldn't
work at some point you owe so I sat out
and I just said I'm going to do what it
is that I would like to watch where
people told me there weren't enough
people out there like me and then that
ended up being the audience and then
eventually Mud Club and those are the
people we owe so the vision is you are
investing in us to entertain and to
fight for you well that's what we're
able to do without the shackles that a
lot of other people come with
so so there is so there's not really a
um there's not really a okay so you know
daily wire is going to be watching this
tonight so you and I know you can't say
yes or no but they're watching this okay
and they're watching to size you up
they're watching to see if you guys are
going to be able to compete with them or
not the world of competition is very
brutal and they there you know that I
don't need to tell you any that they're
watching it and by the way whether
they're gonna say they watch it or not
you know sometimes you're like oh did
you watch it now no should I bet you
know so well a true competitor which
they are they'll be watching this now
here's a question
if
if the vision is like that so it's not
like you guys are here saying we're
going to build one of the largest media
companies and be able to do XYZ and
fight the fight against the you know the
uh woke the establishment but what
they're doing we're gonna do our part
and we're going to build a company
that's going to be able to go out there
and fight for the average conservative
in America for the values and principles
that we have and by doing so we're going
to be able to build a multi-billion
dollar company to do movies
documentaries shows they're that's not
the vision that's not what you're
selling or is that no that's that's not
what but here's here's the big
difference so for example you can bring
in someone who's let's say is immensely
talented like a world-class stand-up
comedian so people who are working with
okay you can bring them in and say by
the way or a documentary filmmaker who
yeah we have some people so different
people who we and we'll be making
probably tomorrow there might be some
announcements as far as you know you
have tentative agreements but there'll
be at least twice the content starting
March 20th okay and eventually triple
it'll be quadruple as long as no one has
to compromise what what it is they
believe but we don't bring in for
example a world-class stand-up comedian
and say you need to do a daily show that
you don't want to do and then a
documentary we say hey you're looking to
do a special let us give you a a
Tailwind let us be the win under your
sales for that special you're a comedian
be the Best comedian you can be we're
not trying to fit them into a box and
then if a documentary filmmaker comes in
and says hey I want to make this film
it's going to cost x 100 000 or x
million dollars to produce it we don't
go okay you can do that but you have to
do a b c x y z for us to fund that we
say okay great be the best documentary
filmmaker that you can be the issue is
there really is no platform out there
where people can be exactly who they are
without certain strings attached that
may not be by the way with any malicious
intent but it ends up having the same
net result where it becomes very very
homogeneous you and I both know this on
the conservative like there's a reason
it's really easy for the left to say
look they're boring it's a bunch of a
bunch of well Tucker Carlson like on CNN
Crossfire days with a bow tie it's a
Tucker Carlson look-alike convention
right
this this is this is your conservative
movement where it all looks and sounds
everyone on the left I mean how here's
here's the the best most effective
attack that someone on the left can do
okay
and we'll get this sometimes we'll be on
the show and like you just mentioned
Anderson Cooper right or sometimes like
Chris Cuomo yeah where you just run the
clip
and that's it it the setup is its own
punch line because it's so bad it
doesn't require commentary that happens
a lot from people on the right where if
you're maybe some people go I really
like what they're saying so they don't
realize how it comes across maybe to
someone who's just looking for the
content side of it and you'll see the
left often they'll just run something
and go
all right there you go and they'll move
on you think so not all not all the time
but sometimes yeah yeah because okay so
there's a reason they put together reels
hit reels for us listen I'm not an owner
of Fox I don't know shares I look at you
know I watch what Russell Brand did
yesterday two days three days ago on uh
what do you call it Bill Maher and he
called that that MSNBC person and he was
stuck so Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam well you
tell me you know you keep calling out
the Fox News but how about you guys what
have you done look at yourself so tell
me one thing that we've done that says
you're serious you want me to talk about
Joe Rogan so yeah and it was so
embarrassing I don't you saw I'm
assuming you saw this yeah actually I
don't know if I could uh I think I'll
because I'm in Florida be doing a show
tomorrow oh fantastic and then like Lex
Friedman like I said I'm this is I'm
doing press for a couple of weeks right
before we phenomenal yeah so so himself
when he comes so so then even Bill Maher
was almost uncomfortable like oh okay
like Melissa slow down well no no it's
really also [__] meaning there was a
moment where the left could do that with
the right but some are saying Fox could
come up right now and say listen we are
the King Kongs to day yeah number one
comedy Greg Gutfeld is doubling camel
and Fallon combined okay so that's data
they'll say that they'll say tucker is
what 2.6 2.7 million and number two as
well they'll say out of the top 20 shows
we have the blah blah blah okay you look
at the bottom down lemon where he's at
these things you've heard I've heard we
see the data and it's very easy for them
to take the shot the way they do right
like Joe Rogan oh you want to talk as
much crap as you want to talk about Joe
Rogan 11 million an episode that one you
know data that came out with the podcast
I don't know if you remember this was
like a year ago maybe nine months ago
when it came out everybody was silenced
hey here's how much just kidding so so
the fox could throw their weight around
and say yeah you guys can say whatever
you want we are still kicking everyone's
ass gut Phil Tucker this that they can
push their weight around sure the only
the only thing I'm asking from you is I
hope they do yeah no I hope they do and
I hope they start you know supporting
real like conservative causes and
candidates and a lot of people see Fox
News as Republican not so much I'm not
I'm not a Fox News Republican I'm I'm a
traditional conservative what's the
difference
uh well the difference for example would
be if you look at the way they treated
certain candidates uh I mean for example
if you look at like what happened with
Kerry Lake and the question the loaded
questions that they would ask the same
thing where if you look at the way they
would treat Donald Trump the same thing
if you look when I was there and Mitt
Romney was kind of a coronation uh the
same thing if you look at some of the
topics that they'll cover whether it's
covering you know the gender bender
that's going on with bathrooms like some
a lot of the time because I know that I
would tune into it and it doesn't
represent what it is that I believe or
certainly I should say not the entirety
of it
um and a lot of conservatives feel that
way certainly a lot of conservatives
after the election
um there's one thing to say like look
the lawsuits were terrible and of course
they were like we were on there reading
the amicus briefs it's another thing to
say anyone who thinks that there was an
issue going on with the election is
crazy and I'm not by the way not
everyone is the same there like Tucker
is very different from someone like a
Greg Gutfeld who's very different from
uh I don't necessarily know all the
other Ingram Laura Ingram Kennedy and
yeah everyone has different points of
Janine and Judge Jeanine yeah I had done
uh Herschel quite a bit on the weekend
she's actually she's a lot of fun she
was a lot of fun to hang out with she
she carries a stick when she goes out
she's not afraid to but here's the thing
I don't see it as competition because
our viewership isn't 74. it's not a 74
year old and I'm not just saying as a
slate that is the median viewership it
might be something it's not that high
though I know it's in the 60s that high
it's in the 70s let's call it 65. sure
2018 yeah 28 years old and not that we
don't Target young people to give you an
idea a lot this is kind of what you were
saying about I see where the puck is
going not where it is now what time is
going it's just it's who I am and so I'm
able to speak to that group of people
the issue is I think you need to reach
all of them the problem is it was never
profitable to reach younger people and
that's why the median demo just got
older and older and older and older
because it's a lot harder to get a bunch
of 20 and 30 year olds to tune in it's
much much more difficult than to uh have
the current conservative base two that's
what's not the same thing and by the way
I hope they reach those people look the
baby boomer generation two they were in
conservative generations of all time I'm
just I'm the only one saying there isn't
only one way to skin a cat because I've
had to do it and been told that it would
never work and that's what hopefully we
can provide for other people out there
who who feel the same way there are a
lot of people in the industry and March
20th you know people are going to see uh
they're looking forward to them people
have been begging for you to come back
for for a while we have a much younger
demo than Fox News we we do of course
by the way your what time did Yoshi is
it 11 o'clock they do your show is it uh
when you would was it 11 A.M is it it's
10 a.m Eastern right 10 a.m 10 a.m 10
a.m East okay I know that because we're
9 to 11 is our show and then I was like
oh Stephen Crowder no no it's great
but the point is the point is that's the
amount of influence you've developed now
for us you know we're in the space we
have a message our audience shows up
maybe our audience is slightly different
than yours they come because they follow
business and we follow business stories
yeah it's not necessarily the same thing
so it's not I don't see us competition
no any more than I see Fox News or what
other people like really wires but where
I'm going with this on on the fox part
and what you're saying is
um okay so here's a different question
for you as somebody that is and talks
about a lot of people right now we're
going to be signing some talent and we
want to bring them on board to
valuetainment we're going to be doing
that because that's part of what we want
to do we have a vision where valetama
wants to go what could could the could
daily wire had really done anything to
have kept you meaning you know some
relationships don't work out yeah and
you're kind of like dude like I really
don't want this relationship to work out
and we're very good to not make a
relationship you're dating a girl you're
like
I have a lot of fun with you we're never
going to be married and we're never
going to have kids so let me create a
problem hey rude let me tell you pal you
know you're going to say oh my God I
can't believe you said you know what I
was thinking about the other then you
know I was thinking about I was having a
fantasy about going and doing this I
would never could oh this this is why I
don't think it's going to work out it's
not you it's me and I boom and you
follow okay how much fantasy that
involves a parrot tube of lipstick three
sticks of butter yeah
yeah it's what we call the litmus test
yeah I got four sticks of butter in my
world but hey were you were you really
open to the idea going daily wire or not
yeah yeah and by the way it wasn't it
wasn't just them just to be clear
they've been a lot of suitors uh sure of
course yeah um so let me let me just
yeah so we were we were doing the uh the
Nashville show right you were doing
stand up about the Ryman which is yeah
and the the whole thing there was like
you know we we had some of the guys were
there from daily wire we knew they were
going to be there and we're like you
know there's just a lot of stress and a
lot of pressure like I really want to
perform well because this after the
election stream on Rumble that week just
yeah it was went crazy and so he was
very much in the mode of like I really
want to perform well I want to show
these guys what kind of stuff we can do
in in the live space as well doing stand
up and not just on the show right so the
answer to that question is yes like
there wasn't nervousness because he was
like I just don't like these guys and I
don't want to do anything with them ever
it was like I really want something to
be possibly to be able to work out but
he said it many many many times there
was just something in there that we've
spec we've specifically gone into it
that just is a non-starter all the other
terms all the other stuff you get to
right in negotiations that was the thing
that I didn't like it was like of course
you negotiate yes but if there's
something in there that basically says
in this term sheet that you're going to
do something that it just it's
antithetical to who we are then no we
can't get past that like that's just
some something that's never going to
work so that's why I said look just take
me out of this let's just talk about the
movement he's talked about a bench
that's part of the vision of what we're
doing how is there another Stephen
Crowder in this current age will Fox
News step up and go into a newer media
category and try to reach a younger
audience and swing the big stick that
they have to do something for the
conservative movement it's bigger than
that bigger than that right will they
stand up and do that and so when we're
looking at we're like well we don't want
to just do this and then kind of right
off into the sunset we want other people
to be able to come up and do this as
well yeah because there needs to be more
than just Fox News there needs to be
more options for conservative stuff so
you guys do want to build something as
big as Fox News if not bigger not as big
as Fox News oh yeah like I've talked
about with YouTube is look I will build
we will build something that will be as
big as it grows to be provided that we
can believe in what it is that we're
building in other words if it comes to a
point where I go okay but
we gotta start we got to start silencing
ourselves and discussing these issues
because look at the look at the 10 15
million we've foregone on YouTube the
minute I find myself making this yeah
I'm done can I ask you a question on the
money then yeah um you know they say
everyone has a price yeah and 50 million
I'm 50 million okay I think that was
that was my price yeah one night
you never heard me talk about the money
it was 12.5 million in a Content that
would go six for an entire production
company with a 110 penalties at minimum
right 45 actually 65 of which would have
been enacted immediately like could have
been redlined and eliminated okay we
have 25 30 employees we have millions of
dollars that we have to pay just in
equipment costs and insurance costs
right the costs and for us are in the
few million dollars per year just to
operate the show and you know doing this
that's not gonna probably about right
yeah so take I will put a bigger number
with the work that you do some of those
things you actually act you do skits you
do you mean it's not like a lot of
production costs yeah yeah we had to
bring an entire uh a one and a half like
metric ton of sand into a Saving Private
Ryan
we have to have lawyers on retainer like
crazy because some of the [__] we do is
horrendous sorry can I say yeah you just
did I apologize like sometimes we look
back and we go like did we do that but
he said that whether it's 50 million you
said even if it was a billion no yeah
that you're you're you're ideologically
opposed to what was going on with big
Tech censorship yeah everything like
that there's no future to believe in if
if we do the bidding of big Tech and by
the way no amount of money no this is a
hill you will die nothing more
predictable than me yeah there would be
nothing more profitable than me for
example leaving getting a bunch of
people to sign up for mug Club right now
just the People by the way who've
already entered in their email at mug
Club forever there would be no way to
make more money than for me to say sign
up do it for two years not produce any
other shows pocket the money and walk
or to have done that before that would
be the money play the money placard
certainly wouldn't be bleeding money to
bring in Talent right to try and produce
content we don't need to do it but
really and this is the challenge we run
into is
um there are very few people who we can
bring in who would be for example like
an exposure benefit for us but we don't
really care we know that we can be an
exposure benefit for them and there are
a lot of good people out there who've
had the door slammed in their face and
yeah I know some of them have had the
door slammed in their face at Fox News
at some of these other places because
there are very specific instances of
them not playing ball that they
shouldn't have to play I'm not talking
about anything really pernicious I'm
talking about like hey don't discuss
these issues hey you know don't be so
rough around the edges some people need
to be and that's okay only one side is
saying we don't need to do it one way so
we'll be as successful as it is based on
people saying what it is they believe
and not compromising it but it's just a
different starting goal right I use this
analogy with pastors like your job as a
pastor is not to grow your church your
job as a pastor is to Faithfully convey
the word of God to whoever shows up and
let God take care of the growth it's
just the focus is slightly different
right so we're saying look our goal is
not to grow a company and become a
behemoth like Fox News or anybody else
that's out there our goal is to make
sure that there's a pathway for creators
and that the audience is always the
number one the only person that we have
to perform for that's the audience
what's that Jew and if that into your
church I want you to get me to convert
yeah there you go well we can talk about
this I went to Ministry School your goal
could be if you're Joel Osteen's
stuffing money in the wall yeah you got
to put that somewhere and you need
insulation so guys so uh obviously the
left has a choke hold on think about it
when you name name the top five
conservative we were having problems
coming up with yeah three they have a
choke hold and it takes like thank God
little moments like Elon who's I don't
really know where he's political but he
buys Twitter we're seeing fathers seeing
the lives we're seeing all this [__]
with the league Lively do you guys do
you think Steve like the the tides are
shifting and people like you like what
Pat's doing what you guys are doing do
you think it's there's light at the end
of the tunnel there's the other side the
other boys yeah you know it's a good
question there's definitely been a shift
so actually I wanted to go back to
something and this kind of ties in that
uh that Patrick said
um he said Niche I don't have the
numbers but I remember uh a Breaking Bad
I think there was about 14 million it
was 12 million people tuned into the
finale and when they did some focus
groups I believe it was like 80
something it was a significant majority
were Republican take the highest
viewership ever on Fox News it's still
about a third of that so when people say
oh what you do is more Niche now no and
I think even like we don't really talk
about our numbers a whole lot they're
reflected in that right with no seed
money it's not Niche to have an
entertainment show that people will tune
into whether they're conservative or not
I would say it's more Niche to just do
rah-rah talking points because if you
look there's a huge con think of how
many people vote Republican and you're
talking about like these huge numbers
right Fox News like Tucker is like two
point something million three million is
a huge Peak and that's what the Nielsen
rating right where the viewership is for
seconds right you're lucky if it's a
couple of minutes
um I think that's more Niche than for
example every single comedy late night
show all of Comedy Central ABC NBC but
it's entertainment it's very different
so going to what you're talking about I
will say this I've noticed a shift when
I was obviously in in the entertainment
industry and then um particularly in the
stand-up Community like in Montreal
there were no people who were even
right-wing or libertarian I mean people
get furious I was I didn't even know it
was conservative but I would go up and I
would make a joke uh that I remember one
time I got in a lot of trouble because
it was a joke about Muhammad uh which
you know yeah people get touchy about it
so I would get in trouble back then uh
and no one understood that there was an
issue with that everyone it was like a
comedy Witch Hunt remember when George
Bush was president everyone just came
out and he sucks isn't he an idiot isn't
he a [__] yeah and it's fine but I was
going there's no no one else at that
point in time
that's changed a lot as a matter of fact
now we're when you go to comedy clubs
and not just people like Rogan but you
see at least a lot of people understand
the idea of Free Speech but you still
get sort of the Indie old Comics who say
like it's not cancel culture it's
accountability culture but really I had
to take we had to take a lot of bullets
early on doing that because there were
there was nobody in the industry doing
it and I think now for some people it's
a little late they've uh woken up and
realized it I think Joe Rogan has done a
lot to help with that obviously you're
talking about his numbers it's
unbelievable
um you see like someone like Russell
Brand like I'll be doing a show tomorrow
I hope it goes well because I used to
lay into that guy hard
yeah and he had this I don't know
comments but back then uh he would do
this thing called the true the truce
news all the news that you're not
hearing anywhere else and he would talk
about it and they would he would
constantly go into Fox News and here you
would think that I'm anti-fox news my
issue was I felt compelled to back then
say well hold on a second what about ABC
NBC CBS CNN MSNBC and he wasn't talking
about it back then and I was the only
conservative on YouTube and so I would
dress up like him and do an impression
of him and make fun of him uh and and by
the way not mean spirited like I
understand talented right uh but I don't
think he liked it of course uh and uh
now you see him transition I don't know
where he lines up politically on every
single issue but I do know that he
understands the threat we're facing is
sort of necessary his voice he's
unbelievably necessary that's a
transition though then it was him with
the entire industry yeah and me kind of
in this corner and now it's at least
split it's almost like a Schism in the
church yeah you know yeah a couple other
questions before we before we transition
I want to go into some current events
and I think audience wants to do some
current events there's a bunch of uh
conversations going on here with people
talking but so
um let's say and I'm asking this
selfishly okay and it's just you and I
talking with Gerald okay
is going
you and I alone
turn off the lights
oh no if if if if I wanted to if I
wanted to sign a guy like you okay and
during that time while you're talking a
daily Wire yeah and we sat down and I
was one of the guys on the table where
would I win to be able to attract a
player like you
uh I can tell you one thing there would
have to be at least one percent upside
that's it at least one I mean that's
just where you if the sticking point is
zero percent it's like about 50 past a
certain point of net profit it's like
zero percent right when you're talking
about zero percent upside zero percent
upside zero percent upside got it if you
started with one percent you'd be ahead
of the game okay so that's so what
you're saying is hey I come in I light
this up I don't want you to guarantee me
12 and a half year two years and another
you know up to six years whatever et
cetera et cetera we're gonna just tell
me if I light it up I can make 20. I can
make 30. yeah I can make 40. that's what
I'm that's your biggest thing if you
could do that yeah
that's the starting point it's at least
one it is a sticking point and the big
thing is if you also didn't say by the
way
you have to start changing your show so
you're monetized right yeah I don't know
that would be the issue you didn't do
that you would be a habit of most
if I'm signing a guy like you up uh uh
you're doing Rumble and you're doing
YouTube right and you're everywhere
you're not really active on ever you are
active on Rumble and you're very active
on YouTube and you know what you built
over the years
the goal would be to develop an Ott
monthly subscribership that's going to
build value
and the more dollars you brought there
the math is so easy to structure for a
guy like you why would that be so
complicated
you know someone I'm asking you like I
know I realize if I surface if I set it
up right now I do realize
he said on the table they didn't say at
the table yeah no I'm still alive I do
not consent he's the howling in the
Moonlight like a siren because I'm drawn
to him like Yogi Bear
no but I mean so that's that's what you
would think right and so seeing these
offers come in and literally and I'm not
going to tell you about specifics but
three four offers come in and boom boom
boom cookie cutter cookie cutter and I'm
like do you eat had you even seen the
show like you're not some startup
company coming out where we're gonna do
five live reads I'm sorry if that's your
thing that's fine that's just not us
it's just that's not what we do they
don't I don't even so why would you try
to make us fit in that box if you didn't
say we're gonna pop you know 110
penalties on behalf of YouTube on behalf
of Facebook on behalf of uh uh Spotify
and on Apple iTunes and apple all this
stuff if uh sorry that's right it's not
iTunes anymore I just showed how old I
am remember back when it used to be
iTunes like apple music all right
um that and any percentage of upside
especially if let's say you had access
to the numbers of of uh you know mug
Club subscribers and you knew you'd be
making far more than your initial offer
anyway you'd be way ahead of the game
but that that was a complete stick and
not just just to be clear yeah it's
never been about daily wire it really is
about the industry and how it operates
and I know what these term sheets I know
what contracts should look like because
I've been on the secular side of it for
two since I was 12 years old I mean I
was having to be tutored on set yeah but
but okay so let's go a little bit deeper
with that so if that was the case and I
said look I don't give a get a strike I
don't give you do this I don't give you
get any I don't care if you get
demonetized on YouTube yeah that's a
part of the revenue that's coming in
if you're bringing XYZ amount of
subscribers to Ott that's what's going
to be the measuring of your success you
drive the hell out of this five million
bucks for every XYZ the amount of
subscribers you bring in hey Pat I got
this many active cut them a check for
another five billion yeah so every time
it's like million million million
million hey we did this one two second
year you made 20 made 22 million this
year great I hope you make 40 next year
yeah there is a way to structure the
math to do that I don't think that's
like uh well not to be Advertiser
dependent too like there's some role
that advertisers play we love the
Partnerships that we have yeah very very
picky about it we don't just do ads the
same way people do we actually do these
really funny commercials they get tons
of plays on right clip channels on
YouTube but it basically makes it and
Elon even said this he's like you got to
go away from the advertising reminder
he's talking about Twitter exactly play
a role but you can't depend on it
because they dictate that it's like a
diversified portfolio the fact that he's
doing that because you know the whole
750 million dollars one of them and
dropped I was like what are we going to
do with this if we lose this well if you
do you kind of have to answer to them
the other day I was watching Fox and I
saw an ad on Fox
I saw him like interesting you're now
okay with this ad and you're doing that
you did the show with trends like nine
months ago I don't know if you remember
yes okay but if you go to Ott model to
drive and the multiple there is based on
how many paid subscribers and your job
is to create constant creative content
shows to say you're only going to get
this on the Ott yeah and that's how you
get compensated
well so for example like some of the
people who we're talking with right now
like some of them we know they're not
going to be generating a bunch of paying
subscribers right and they also don't
necessarily generate like YouTube
Revenue some of these people have you
know history of background like really
large you know main network shows where
they've been a part of comedy shows
these comedy specials and so we bring
them in we say okay what is it that you
want to do what is it you bring to the
table and then you find that intersect
and you see where you can work together
we know not everyone is going to have
the paying subscribership that we have
but here's the thing
we've always focused on trying to add
value that's why we've reduced the price
by ten dollars which people would say is
absolutely crazy while adding content
because we've made the numbers work from
our end we want our viewers and
particularly the people who we know felt
like they were left out in the cold who
paid and like well I signed up here and
you're leaving after four months they're
going to get a bunch of Time free True
North is the audience what they want and
how you serve them and when you start
with that you will then look at the
people who you are working with Talent
OR Purdue and say how do you serve the
audience not how do you serve a
corporate Overlord not that there's
anything wrong with corporations not how
do you serve these people on the second
floor who you but how do you serve the
audience and the beauty with the
audience is it's more than half of
America it's more than half of the
United States of America and that is not
reflected when we talk about these
numbers look that's not two that's not
three million certainly not at you know
45 seconds to a minute and a half a pop
that is these people are basically
they're out there and there's nothing
for them yeah and I was one of those
guys yeah and you know the way you
you're describing it when I saw so uh
Fox is Republican I'm more conservative
okay daily wire is this and you know
those guys are this or those guys the
way I'm seeing it is you know on the
conservative side Republican side it's
like different denominations of
Christianity you got Presbyterian
seven-day LDS Catholic you know pick
them right whatever you may be you're
pretty much following the same
Commandments you may be off 90 your
profit is a different person you you
know your your NIV is the Bible you
follow you follow book of Moroni or you
follow this but the structure of what
you believe in more or less is the same
the challenge then becomes if there's a
massive infighting and uh where you are
fighting for the same cause but it's
going up against each other that could
be problematic because then the the
cause of wanting to inject or you know
sell the values and principles that you
believe in now it's kind of confused
because daily wire what do we have are
these guys supposed to be enemies are
those guys supposed to be enemies so
that's the only challenge where some
viewers might have but to say I know I
understand that by the way I do believe
you bring an audience to daily wire that
they don't have I do believe that I do
believe that Jordan Peterson brings an
audience that they don't have I do
believe praker brings a different
audience that they may not have I do
believe Candace brings a different
audience and definitely Shapiro is the
the guy that brings a different audience
so it's not like the people that already
listen to daily wire all of them
subscribe to you there's a different
audience again I think it's also
important to note like this is the first
time it's ever been from me any kind of
infighting people have asked about we
don't even talk about the numbers on our
show I don't talk about it because I I
just feel dirty I want the content to
speak for itself it's very very rare
there are a lot of things that have
happened behind the scenes for years
that we just don't talk about in dealing
with this industry it is the one in Soul
time and that's because yeah I know Joe
was about to jump in you have state
borders and you have National borders so
for example when you talk about
Christianity uh yeah there are state
borders that's maybe a presbyterian or
maybe your Methodist but then you do
have National borders right and that's
where you would say you have Catholic
and you have Protestant that would be
considered I'm sure we share a lot of
the same values but certainly let's just
go on the Protestant side if you get
into that territory where you say okay
yeah I'm a Protestant I'm a Bible
believing you know I'm a born again
Christian but I don't believe hell
exists that's a national border we no
longer share the same Faith because
Jesus came to save us from the fires of
hell now you are in a different religion
sure and so if our entire reason for
being at least us
is to fight big Tech and fight this
Leviathan that we have seen for so long
you know what we have talked about
always right it's been flipping the bird
to the mainstream not just media but
entertainment industrial complex and big
Tech
well we can't compromise that because
now we're Beyond National borders and
everyone else also would espouse those
same values and people think they're
fighting that you have a sponsorship to
do no I don't know
instead of looking at it as infighting
because you're right the church a lot of
times can be Its Own Worst Enemy look at
it as hopefully ironing iron sharpening
iron right so we're trying to sharpen
the movement and push it forward in the
right direction and we never picked a
fight with daily wire and we haven't
talked about this when we have a massive
platform it wasn't a pick wasn't picking
a fight pick the fight though but
there's nothing wrong with you
right so think about what we did in that
first video yeah we said these are the
terms in the industry and these this
just cannot work this way we're gonna go
and do something different yeah that's
it that's what we did now if people are
gonna suppose okay this is the daily
wire and we didn't come out with
personal attacks or anything like that
I'm not I'm not saying that they did I'm
just saying that wasn't like infighting
that's not me saying like I'm a
Protestant you're a Catholic and you
guys are completely off base I can't
believe it you can't go have fellowship
with these guys but because they believe
if you don't do the sacraments that
you're not saved how can you possibly
believe that that's not what happened
right our goal was to say hey for us to
survive for this thing to be real and
not just talking into a camera and
hopefully making some money we have to
do better we have to do better as a
movement otherwise we will go away yeah
eventually it will just end look you
guys have a people out there have a
choice right you have a choice do you
want a movement that includes people who
are not behold into big Tech who do not
punish their creators on behalf of big
Tech who do not say you have to be
monetized by the way we will have
content creators who are monetized on
YouTube that's the thing some people
have come to us and said well we want to
I go great do it how you want to do it
but we have some people who come in and
say I really want to be less dependent
on YouTube and that gets me more excited
yeah do you want a movement that
exclusively is beholden to cocktail
parties with big Tech or also allow some
room for some Rebels with a cause
flipping the bird being a little bit
rough around the edges do you want all
of these things depends what the vision
is though right if the vision like my
division doesn't matter company though
I'm talking about movement at that point
holy get it but again individually you
have a vision collectively we have a
vision right my vision individually may
be different than the vision of the
company those are two different things
let me as a talent forget about me being
a company guy assuming I was just a
YouTuber I have a vision with what I
want to do with the show right the the
vision for me the problem is to talk to
people who disagree with me not to talk
to people who agree with me right that's
mine so for me if the vision is to
convert and persuade
I mean you you know cost of discipleship
is the first book you read when you
become Okay
Christian 101 okay did you say when you
become a gay no Christian you read the
first book which is cost of disciples
yeah and you read mirror Christianity
sure those are two of the books you read
and one of the the whole reason why
we're doing this PVD is to go out there
and you know decide okay so if if our
job is to do that and it's door knocking
and it's talking to them we kind of got
to be places where
people who disagree with us are so for
example I completely agree yeah so if
you go only on Rumble like Chris is a we
had Chris at the house you and I were
with them till I don't know what by the
way the conversation we have with Chris
I said Chris make a public offer to Ray
to Joe Rogan that's the whole time when
he people were worried about Spotify
being I said make a public offer the
next day he made a public offer it was a
great movement yeah so so but what I'm
saying is I said I said If You're Gonna
really do what you if your vision is to
sell the company and be a billionaire
great you got an itch go get all the
conservatives and do what you want to do
but if your vision is to truly make an
impact and persuade and convert you got
to mix it up you got you got to take a
different approach so that's why I think
YouTube is a place where someone think
about how many people I agree but I
think here's the thing here's the thing
because this is what's also like where
would you be without YouTube look I was
there before uh anyone at Daily wire or
Blaze or Fox when I was at Fox News I
would upload I might be at this point at
100 000 subscribers maybe maybe 80 000
subscribers and I remember saying like
hey can I upload some of my hits like I
would appear on red eye or Hannity or
you know Janine I said can I upload
these to my YouTube channel because you
know my people on YouTube there's no way
to reach them it's not like social media
back then they didn't have Community
posts so the only way I can reach them
is if I let them know through my YouTube
video I said sure then legal took them
down because they said we think this
YouTube thing is a fad so no one
understands that better than I do in
reaching new people and I would never
willingly just go let's say to rumble or
a right-wing Echo chamber but this is
something that we have designed from the
ground up where we've said look the free
content is available we will reach as
many people as humanly possible uh
provided we do not have to forbid
ourselves from speaking the truth and
we're able to do that without being
beholden financially this is the model
this is why we've been so fortunate
we're not beholding financially to Big
Tech because of my club because of
subscribers so if we are ever taken off
of YouTube it's because they decide that
we have to go nothing because we decide
but that's fine that's all good and by
the way you know for for people that are
watching this one of the alt time the
most famous memes is you if you want to
pull up and if you just type in Stephen
Crowder meme I think that's used where
everywhere everybody uses that I mean
and they probably don't even know what
this means this meme is literally used
by the chain from the Left Right middle
it doesn't matter it says to change my
mind right so that's the part that's
right yeah
bring up my favorite one tell me okay
type in uh change my mind meme I think
it's a Stevie Wonder oh God have you
seen it no I I think I know I I just
have an idea because so basically just
let me set it up for people if the meme
is uh is it there is it top left
here
so to me to me this takes guts like when
you're saying I get nervous a lot of
people would be scared shitless sitting
they're going to universities that you
go you got you got a lot of all that so
you got a lot of Courage you're very
necessary try doing it on Sixth Street
South by Southwest it's not just on
universities
to do that that's the ultimate in this
world to face that so kudos to you for
doing that anyways uh look I ask you a
lot of a different question I appreciate
you for being a sport and taking it you
know some of the stuff was probably you
know
just so people know you guys had no clue
what we're gonna ask you no I didn't
know you're starting live yeah yeah I
was looking at that size hey hey it says
live on earth you're very nice
yeah hey that's why that's why he's Rich
because he saves money
yeah like he's nice he got a lot of good
qualities but
Rob just sent me a text saying I forgot
one of the sponsors my apologies we have
to do that at the one hour mark uh our
next sponsor is KY Jelly today
[Laughter]
and I know you know the smoke is kind of
cleared have you guys have any
conversations with Jeremy or Ben or any
of these guys for have you spoke I've
had a lot of I would say this like uh um
so Ben and I have no need like I've
always said we've been friendly for a
very long time yeah right you've heard
me say that yes and I really wish that
we you know uh very different like it's
not like Jeremy and I ever had that kind
of a relationship Jordan Peterson yes
Andrew Clavin yes and there are a lot of
people who work there behind the scenes
who are fantastic people who absolutely
um and it's one thing to have
disagreements on a vision for a company
but yeah I've had a lot of a lot of
conversations with people there behind
the scenes so but no as far as business
dealings you know no and uh there would
be nothing better for example than to do
let's say you started let's say you were
talking about figuratively you start a
network there'd be nothing better than
to say hey how about this how about
there's a Cross promo link where someone
who's in Mud Club gets a discount for
your network and they get a discount for
our Network sure we get less money per
subscriber but you hit a critical mass
point and you're not going to have
people using it to steal content I would
do that with any conservative Network
out there the issue is none of them
would do it with any not just me any
other consumers you won't see people do
that because because it's a this
measuring I got you I got a sponsor to
go very good very much okay okay we
literally just did our sponsor with KY
that was that was just a quick shout out
we had for them okay so is that actually
what it was no no no no
I can't try it again
I don't know what to do with this all
right did you read the Santa's book no
okay uh uh I Could Have Lied right
that's one of those things where all
these posts
number to cover I wrote a paper he wrote
a book [__]
did you uh did you did you read it of
course yeah did you watch uh uh CPAC did
you watch CPAC and you know Trump speech
are you following any of that stuff
what's going on yeah you know it's funny
I it's funny you mentioned CPAC imc'd
the main ballroom at CPAC for like hours
11 years ago 12 years four years in a
row yeah or no wait I did it I did it
three years then skipped a year because
I got horrible food poisoning did it
another year and I got called into the
second floor at Fox the brass actually
uh every time I would do CPAC I'd get in
trouble for something oh great and like
one time I went out when Keith Urban was
fired I literally went out and full on
Keith Urban makeup as a DJ uh getting
around my business cards and I was like
introducing Keith Oberman I went out
isn't he like yo super funny no he's
super loud
yeah gentle yes so hard and then one
time I got called in because they had a
joke about uh they someone said that I'd
made a joke about uh about raping Ashley
Judd which wasn't true at all I made a
comment about her saying that purchasing
Apple products is akin to raping the
Earth yeah but I would constantly have
to get brought in and they would say
well you can't even comment on that
because it's a third rail and I would do
a joke so I was like you know what I
don't want to do it anymore oh there you
go that's an old one but I actually at
CPAC went out as key domain on the main
stage selling Maybelline and then I got
trouble
when you get called up into the
principal's office yeah Fox on the
second floor all the time walk me
through what happens they're like all
right Stephen this is it yeah the fourth
time this week yes what did they say to
you they just be they would just here's
the thing I will say too there were some
great people there
um but they wouldn't ever tell me what I
could not say they would just encourage
me with things that would do well with
the audience you know they would ask me
to do things like put on put on a suit
right put on a tie you know uh one this
is this is actually one so as a comedian
right for the Phyllis dealer quote you
it's I didn't learn uh comedy when I
learned how to write I learned comedy
when I learned how to edit exactly right
Whittle it down Whittle it down Whittle
it down and so I would go and I had a
debate segment with Alicia Menendez
Senator Bob menendez's daughter every
Sunday for a long time and as opposed to
you know the goal on cable news is to
run the clock out use up as much time
saying basically repeating the same
point so that your opponent doesn't have
time to speak coming from a stand-up
background coming from you know at that
point you know even the only Sports I've
ever done are you know combat sport like
Jiu Jitsu and stuff not at a high level
but again in my head it's basically
comedy and something like Jiu Jitsu or
Judo where you kind of okay brevity is a
soul of wit uh I would be really really
short so like one point uh I think she
said oh no this was uh Alan Combs I
think who was a super sweet guy so like
ah well you know Stephen uh where did
you go to school when I was making a
point where did you go to school where's
your degree and rather than just going
oh no I just said never made it out of
grade school what's your point yeah and
then gave him two minutes no well I
didn't mean you know there are a lot of
people who are smart who uh you know
maybe don't go to school and then I get
calling well you know what the thing is
when you do that when you just when you
just answer in like five word sentences
it throws off the flow for other people
I'm like
giving them the ball because they've
said nothing yeah so that was one I was
sitting there going like I'm just not
going to run out the clock and just spew
a bunch of stuff to sound ultimately
trying to sound articulate I'd sound
inartically but that was one where I was
like um this may not be the right you
know but it doesn't sound like they're
critiquing and I think they're kind of
giving it's almost like you've seen the
movie Knocked Up when they're like when
uh what the girl's character comes in
they're like we're not saying you need
to lose weight just gotta tighten it up
there was one a little bit they paired
me up my producer to do a comedy show
that once you're like well maybe there's
something to this and the guy was a
super sweet guy
super old I mean like in his 80s and uh
he would like ask me the questions like
what do you think of a Steve Allen you
know that kind of thing yeah and uh or
Mike Douglas you know and uh I remember
basically kind of pitching what it is
that we do now and they wanted to have a
monkey on the show like on the set a
real monkey the real monkey which I was
like I mean all right but like I don't
feel like you're hearing the rest like
what about this monkey it'll be crazy
what if we can we get a roller skating
monkey and I remember being like okay
we're just we're on two different
wavelengths and that's why what we
talked was like all I'm saying is you
need to have multiple wavelengths not
just one yeah because it's always one on
our side of the on our side of the
spectrum unfortunately and it makes
makes a lot of people out there feel
disenchanted I mean do you have any idea
how lonely I felt when uh you'd sit
there and they go well conservatives
don't want uh something like change my
mind I think I do well conservatives
don't watch Comedy like I kind of think
I do like ah you know conservative
doesn't work conservatives don't want
books that aren't doomsday theories I'm
like I kind of want like productive
Solutions and ways to move forward and
you go and oh I want to go out and
create this show but is there anyone out
there like me like is the only way to
create content in this movement for a 70
plus year old demo that's straight laced
and red meat and there's nothing wrong
with that but it's really scary when you
say Okay can it only be that so there
was a big step out in faith at one point
I said I took this is the story of the
show I took it uh it was on radio for
three hours on and I didn't want to do a
radio show but they said hey Bill
Bennett takes off uh he has a fill-in
host on Fridays so it's a morning drive
nine to uh or six to nine I said well
okay that's a prime slot on radio and
it's once a week for three hours that's
great and the people who are syndicating
the show said yeah we we technically
with our contract we can do it so I said
okay I'm gonna be based out of a station
in Detroit and don't pay me anything do
a REV split but and at this point I
didn't have a show uh my own show I said
but uh you know let me own the rights to
do podcasts which they thought that's a
fad you know a lot of people and then
started getting syndicated to more and
more Marcus as well you're this would
have been 2013 2014. something like that
sounds about right that's you know post
[__] before that I just been I had been
a contributor to Fox News had been you
know done stand up and acting but at
this point I said okay I'm going to
create the show that I want and what
happened and the reason we ended up
doing so many bizarre sketches is AM
radio has 16 minutes of AD space but the
problem is when you're streaming it on
YouTube which at that point no
conservative was doing like they don't
want to hear about Ypsilanti Chevrolet
so I would just go uh uh the dating
advice with Bill Cosby we create a
stinger in and out and I'm like uh uh
Michael Jackson Redux and every single
song was about like six-year-old boys
like uh we're gonna do the first
recipient of a penile implant like and
you and I would do 16 minutes of
sketches times three we just found all
this stuff by the way in in it
we had over no it was over 600 old
commercials on AM radio you've never
launched this never never no we we
reused some of them uh like Perry Mathis
was a character that we would do fake we
got in trouble with the FCC you know
that ah
yeah and we would do fake warnings
we were like we have a you know at that
point like we have Elena Dunham morning
and there's just some fat joke right
yeah but then they say Hey you know like
this is a legal like the specific sounds
like signifying you this is highly
illegal what I was like well okay I'll
stop that but then they realize it was
only online and they realized that at
that point people are listening to it on
audio like as a podcast like so they
don't okay at this point they don't
think it's an emergency so so fine but
we were getting into trouble all the
time and uh at that point in time
remember it was before we launched mug
club we were like well you know what we
only had like 12 000 people who would
tune in because it was already once a
week three hours like I don't know if
it's gonna work but let's and then 12
000 became 50 000. that became a couple
hundred thousand that became into the
millions but we just found these it was
over 600 audio commercials that we only
ever ran once yeah a lot of them for
maybe 12 000 people aside from the radio
are crazy like 200 sketches and opens
and like all these things we just got
all this content sitting there that
we're like that's a lot of good stuff to
participate yeah they want to see some
of this yeah you again put the link
below if you want to learn more about it
mug Club
forever.com
both links below for them to have a
Robert if you can do that as a reminder
go back so the Santa's Trump curious to
know where you're at with this okay the
Santa's Trump or you're you're seeing
why are you laughing
because this question right now is the
third rail in the Republican Party
yeah
numbers or what 60 to 20 right CPAC
whatever that what were the numbers that
you saw yesterday
right only within CPAC right which is
now called tpack for Trump yeah so where
are you with this where are you here's
the thing
um I like qualities from both can I know
this is going to sound like but I'm
certainly not a fence sitter the truth
is I've never been in the business of
endorsing candidates
um obviously once it gets to a general
people know where I line up yeah but
other people all the time ask me like
hey can you endorse this cam like I
don't think you really know what it is
that I do as a matter of fact even with
guests we'll have people tune out if we
have a guest on because people want to
hear kind of what we're saying about a
topic unless it's a real needle mover
we've had that with who you would well
what an interesting thing you just said
which I feel I hate because it's like I
want hey pay attention to this person
you're like this is boring because we
just came from you know me being
waterboarded or having a [__] Jesus
and Santa vessel in jail whatever the
hell it is I would vote for any of these
people in a national election of course
like I would I really hope it's just not
a super bloody primary yeah people ask
me what I like about Donald Trump I like
the fact that he went off and did it on
his own I like the fact that he's an
outsider
um I don't like the fact that sometimes
he what it is with Donald Trump is even
if
he thinks he might be wrong let's assume
and that's a big if he would never admit
it until he has to dig in his heel so
something like with the vaccine you know
was an issue and then really you saw
with the audience when he was
encouraging younger people that was
something that I had a real problem with
um but I like him a lot I think he
certainly has been probably the most
effective president in my lifetime
Rhonda Santos I like that he has really
been consistent as a governor he's done
great things for Florida again I don't
live here but everything that we've read
and covered
um he seems to be a management
remarkably consistent what I don't like
is yeah that he's not a super wealthy
guy and so you are always concerned if
to use the term The Establishment wants
him because they feel like they can get
their hooks right right you always oh
I'm not saying he does but that's the
concern so there are qualities that I
like with both of them uh I really hope
it's not as as childish although you
know oh my God it's gold because I mean
think about Steve he's right deceected
yeah
right up to the focus group get Frank
Lutz with your Snickers and two pay
let's see what's best yeah yeah
it's like Trump is dude think about it a
lot of the stuff that he was telling
everybody about about the virus and he
was right yeah but the rush about
everything so it's like he has not
[__] chip on his shoulder bro yeah he
has anger and now I mean Ron is just in
his way but bro we talked about this the
last week when I was like I would much
rather me personally go back three years
ago when just the only thing that was
being hurt was people's feelings not the
country like okay tell me right now [__]
isn't messed up right now oh yeah of
course well but the choice now is
between Trump and Biden that that that's
that comparison right now what we're
saying is like if you have Donald Trump
in the office or if you have Ron
DeSantis or maybe some third person that
we don't really know about as much yet
you're gonna have a much better
situation than you do right now right so
it's going to be fantastic I think the
issue with with Trump or any other camp
like we've got to get out of the Messiah
worship kind of mentality in politics in
general yeah there's no one is coming to
save you because nobody is perfect we're
all human beings we're all flawed Donald
Trump was incredibly effective yes
highly effective hilarious as well like
the stuff that he did was like what do
you think
[Applause]
when he's like I heard people say this
and he could just interject whatever he
wanted to say about somebody but
couldn't actually on that debate stream
I don't think so at that point when he I
just remember sitting like did he just
say his dad killed JFK what the hell did
he just say no about Ted Cruz yeah we
should want the very best candidate
possible to be the Republican nominee
that's what we should want we don't need
a bloodied candidate that's just been
completely destroyed and then here come
the Democrats again with somebody who's
going to kill the country yeah look
we've got to have bigger goals than just
getting our guy into office yeah
disagree with Trump when he says I alone
can fix it is that what you're saying
because you're saying that you don't
want to I would disagree with anybody
who says I alone can fix it yeah I don't
think anybody alone can fix this because
Donald Trump was in the office for
really three years right yeah no but he
was in there for three years then he had
to deal with the pandemic he was making
a lot of positives somebody else will
have to carry the torch he's got a he's
got a window of eight years and then the
establishment will come roaring back
right the machine will come back you've
got to be able to hand the torch off to
the next guy yeah keep it going for the
next eight years not one person can do
this if DeSantis does get elected let's
just go hypothetical here do you think
that it would be a negative that he is
quote unquote establishment I don't
think he's establishment my concern is
that he could end up owing the estate
that's my point is that like
Donald Trump impossible to work with
it's the same reason it makes him almost
establishment proof to some degree he
had a lot of people in his cabinet who
you would consider sort of swamp
creatures right but as far as them being
able to tell them to be like go screw
yourselves I know better right he
doesn't care
um so I'm not saying DeSantis is it's a
concern that he would be more prone to
being influenced by it which it could be
completely ill-founded and I'm not super
concerned about I'm just trying to you
know Express concerns with both of them
yeah I don't like the quote you know the
old quote whatever kills you makes you
stronger doesn't I mean what happens if
you end up being like a quad amputee
like no yeah quadrupleter none of that
is true whatever killer itself aside
from Trump doesn't every candidate kind
of have to owe somebody some money yeah
like how many billionaire candidates
have there been that's why I always find
yeah exactly which I loved him spending
a ton of his own money and losing yeah
that was fantastic he got mad because we
had we had a guy dressed as Bloomberg
come in where he was like he was doing
like he was dancing
yeah yeah we said it and then someone
came and said did somebody say Bloomberg
he started doing the worm and like put
down a cardboard box and that guy is so
humorless his people got mad like we
really didn't like the depiction of him
yeah you can go screw yourself
as a comedian you must have loved
Trump's whole thing like now Mike wants
to bring a a platform on stage yeah
oh now he's asking for it's like and he
never happened he's like listen I'm
hearing you and you nailed it I missed
the funny like oh no it was a lot of fun
because now it's just I would get on
Twitter and be like what did he say
today yeah yeah because now it's just
okay Biden fell down the stairs and he's
he has no idea where he is or what he's
saying he's shaking hands there that's
funny but Trump was just volatile and he
would just say what dude the best is
when he would go off teleprompter
because you know when he's reading yeah
and he's reading but then when he's just
like when he's talking [__] he's going
right at you yeah yeah and I just love
it I did a series actually which I think
is why Trump has never been on the show
I think it was offended it was a trump
talk Series in 2015.
yeah but it was like and it was just a
series of like Trump on China Trump on
you know the Border uh and what
invariably he would come back to say and
now other people have kind of noticed it
like this the theme was he would say
look Chad is a crepo that and I would
never say that that's what so many
people think they tell me I would never
say that they say oh it's a hole of crap
and I said you stop
it
and we would do this like back then that
was and now everyone kind of talks about
it but it is true like when he wants
that comfortable deniability oh it's
like people say that
he's doing a meatball run right now yeah
right I'll never say meatball run people
are saying meatball run and I would
never do I would never do it other
people for other people but it's just
just like what Chris Rock Chris Rock
just did with the Wilson he's like he's
like everybody called him a [__] this
person called him a [__] he's a [__] I
never called him he said like a ten
thousand times it was hilarious but this
is back obviously pre like when we had
that was me and my dad you yeah me and
my junior Den yeah we have a better
Trump thing now so I mean that's cool I
mean you just let me play the audio oh
gosh because 2015 20. so that's a while
ago yeah I would never try and do
anything way better well my voice was
shot not because I just did Bernie
come back across the border they're
raping they're killing and frankly Frank
quickly swiftly we have an obesity
epidemic we've got a problem
[Laughter]
my Bernie was always Gilbert talking
about social enemy
what's up with you Capital pieces of
[__] and uh it was just people like why
does it sound like Gilbert Godfrey
because it's funnier it's hilarious I
just enjoy it more yeah it makes me
laughs
oh that was a parody of the scene from
misery
problem
s
but we have some that have millions of
plays where we you know because our
audience no one was paying attention to
Bernie Sanders this is a good example
when we talk about sort of the
establishment people in conservative
media they're all talking about Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton
I remember saying look Hillary Clinton's
a coronation Bernie Sanders is the
movement candidate yeah and we would
actually see a lot of people we have the
you know we have so much data right when
you have billions and billions of plays
across not only just just on YouTube but
then billions on all these other
platforms you can sort of cross
reference and go okay we can actually
see a significant amount of Bernie
Sanders people would come over to Donald
Trump just because of the
anti-establishment yeah sort of Russell
Brand a little bit right where he was a
self-avowed socialist and I don't know
what he would just how he would describe
himself now but he sees the threat of
big Tech like he certainly would be one
of those guys who would have been a
Bernie supporter oh yeah who now sees
the problem whereas this was always our
audience same with Rogan by the way yeah
but that's that going back to a point
that's why that's what Russell said
that's why Rumble exists I mean think
about you were talking about the people
that are on Rumble right now ask
yourself why what did Rumble set out to
do that was different they said look we
we want people to actually be able to
speak freely on this platform right and
they're they're creating something
that's a little bit different over there
and he came out and said the reason they
exist is because YouTube had started to
kind of give everybody
the you know you couldn't say anything
you basically were just choked out if
you were anything close to being
conservative right and so these guys
have come on and said okay well we're
going to let everybody come over here
the first people to jump ship are going
to be the conservatives but watch if
those guys are successful they will
continue to get more people like you
said they have to diversify right
everybody starts out with cat videos
first yeah all right Patrick yeah we
can't all started right it can't always
be built isn't that telling them you're
right all it is it's open to everyone
yeah right it's open to everyone else
say I won't do that I want it closed to
half yeah right that's that's the thing
they've you think Rumble is saying you
can't come here liberal of course not
well but they've got a guy like Russell
Brand and they've got a guy like Joe
Rogan saying it so the movement that we
were talking about earlier like you're
starting to see this Tipping Point maybe
it was your question you are starting to
see people that are going there saying
hey you're right he's he's investing a
lot of money into different people by
the way what are you noticing the
AdSense uh on the way their Platformers
Rumble against YouTube comparing the two
I you know I don't know because I
haven't it would be unfair for me to say
because I've been demonetized for so
long on YouTube so I don't really know
what the industry is like there yeah not
only am I not allowed uh to be monetized
on YouTube I'm not allowed to run ads
through AdSense so to give you other
people can run yeah the exact same ad
like in your Chan we've done a b testing
on this we've done a b testing yeah
where we try and run an ad like let's
just say it's a clip yeah right where
you run as a pre-roll or something say
no absolutely not and then we've had
other people with AdSense accounts who
run it and it gets accepted so it's not
content based it's us-based yeah Peak to
Peak if you were to say you know when I
used to get a million views I would make
seventy eight hundred dollars on YouTube
I'm just making some number up when I
get a million views on Rumble I make XYZ
have you put those two together your
numbers I'm assuming you've done that to
see how they match up with advertising
so that would be more of a Gerald
question again because the rates change
so dramatically that YouTube at Peak was
very different like I think I've been a
partner since 2008 and it was very I was
even around with the mcns like I don't
remember like makers and students of
course yeah of course uh so the rates
would change dramatically so it's almost
like you don't really have a comparison
I will say the numbers have been I think
actually better on a pound for pound
basis uh but we often don't really seek
to monetize the video no because we we'd
rather people feel like they don't have
to watch that and get the show and
subscribe so you don't even monetize on
Rumble right now you're not turning it
on I think it's on for some of them but
we don't spend it's such a small
business model right that's not really
how our model works we for went a couple
million dollars a year from YouTube when
we said okay keep it if you want to
demonetize this because it was you know
the carrot was dangled or just don't
talk about these things we said nope
keep us demonetized just don't don't
remove our Channel and we'll find a way
naive question if you're not making any
money on YouTube and Rumble isn't a
money maker for you yeah is it all the
mug Club all the sponsors yeah okay
because there's so there's the
viewership is so large that one
sponsorship spot is worth you know four
or five on another show so so KY is one
of them they're knocking down now
it's a non-competual so Stephen so uh
people in the mud Club where are they
like on on March 20th yeah correct that
uh you guys are coming back on where
where you guys are launching on like on
your website mainly yeah it's not
entirely finalized but here's the thing
we are launching lotto's lottery.com who
we're still finalizing exactly who is
going to do the back end we're pretty
close got you uh but regardless people
will be able to go there Watch the free
show yeah like we always have and then
continue to watch the premium show and
the additional content on the website on
the website 89 and uh for the whole year
yeah that actually and if and if you are
in my club forever.com where you
subscribe you didn't we're gonna say
send you a code where you actually get a
good few extra free months because of
the situation yeah because that's
something too again because it's like
nothing nothing breaks my heart more
than people saying hey you know I didn't
get a mug or hey you know I subscribe at
this point in time when it's like you
know at some point right you end a
contract at some point you have to like
but I hate that you paid and you only
got half a year but since we can't
access their personal information like
we can't know so it's like you have to
reach out to us and we'll send you this
code it'll largely be honor System where
we do right by you and give you some
extra you know a few few months for free
fantastic that's what I was wishing that
I hadn't taken the CEO job was when we
were getting to the end of the contract
and we had no idea who our subscribers
were
right and we've talked about this and it
was just like okay how do we go and
build this we have no way of getting in
touch with you guys we have yeah you
know like a master email list but that's
that's every single person who's ever
signed up for the newsletter through the
website or through what that number's
got to be in a million it's a lot of
people right but that's the thing it's
not specific and so if you send it a lot
of it maybe it goes to junk mail because
you're sending ads to them potentially
in in previous Partnerships it's like
man like that that's just a feeling of
like we've got to be able to capture
these people so that's where mud clubs
so oh so you brought I don't know if
that was going out the audience but yeah
that's the number of uh three-month
pre-demonetization right
zoom in a little bit go ahead so three
months 430 000 was that uh average from
free demonetization and that's with just
the main channel that doesn't include
Crowder bits about 60 about 62 million
plays
um which is what we're getting an
average in a month between 50 and 70
million and of course that number went
down because you don't get browsers 50
to 70 million views per month yeah okay
wow uh but an average of over a hundred
thousand new subscribers every month
every month and then if you go to uh
demonetization so even we were
demonetized all right we still had about
58 million so the numbers didn't quite
take uh because they it took a while to
get us out of the browse and search uh
forty six thousand so almost to the
letter A tenth every single time they
remonetize us again accidentally someone
got fired wait wait wait this is in 90
days you got how many Subs 46 000.
versus 430 yep yeah that's great
immediately and then we have another did
your show stop did you change any of the
schedule no that's the thing nothing
basically they just turn you off or turn
you on turn you off and then we have
another one they're just doing after
that we're again remonetized right and
then this was oh so we remonetized for
two months
three months there so 213 and again it
took a little while to get but again 62
million plays and then demonetized again
and it went down to 23. and this is just
YouTube it's just you now you've seen
what's happened obviously with someone
like Andrew Tate right where you see
Meta steps in and then Google YouTube
Uber accounts Uber got canceled all that
Airbnb we've been banned from Airbnb oh
really yeah there's a reason do you want
another reason
is
yeah so what happened is remember do you
remember Raz Simone was like he was like
the warlord yeah
then we did some research on him and we
found out that Raz Simone uh actually
had an Airbnb and like got all these
grants from the government so what we
did was we sent our producers down to
Chas we rented out as Airbnb and
declared it new Chas oh my God and spray
painted new Chas and all this stuff and
we actually handed out for sure we
actually handed out party uh Flyers his
ice maker come join new Chaz oh my God
and he found it and actually our guys
got chased out so this whole live stream
was come to New chats which was Airbnb
yeah the Socialist gun club uh showed up
and chased them out with them they're in
jazz oh my god well and he found it so
mid show he actually tweeted us I think
is how we found him he was on Instagram
where he's like you guys are big funny
you know like yeah he actually had a
good sense of humor about it but then he
got his banned from Airbnb oh [__] so
this is his yeah this is Raz Simone's
Airbnb yeah Raz Simone and so you can
see why they wouldn't want us on there
yeah we didn't actually spray paint it
by the way we just did a really good
Photoshop good and we know because they
showed up he was like dude don't he's a
guys don't worry it was Photoshop it was
fake but all right that was good because
the whole idea was it's really easy to
say this is our autonomous Zone when
you're vandalizing other people's crap
so we just said let's go to your Airbnb
that's brilliant and uh yeah so you're
permanently banned from that I think we
had a couple accounts banned from Uber
um anything else I know you're obviously
very against big Tech anything with uh
with meta Instagram Tick Tock well yeah
we've been suspended so that's how I met
my half asian lawyer Bill Richmond was
there he's only half is 100
but he he met me uh through with an
engagement or Gizmodo I always get it
wrong I think it's Gizmodo so it was
like this article that went out and we
were doing millions and millions of
reads on the website just a lot of
credit.com was like it's just a news
site as well and um what happened is all
of a sudden it just got throttled and we
we just couldn't uh generate any type of
traffic anymore and we even a b tested
it on other pages and noticed oh if we
run it on someone else's page it does
well we run into our page it doesn't get
any clicks and so then an article was
released from Gizmodo or what did I say
I don't know
it sounds better it was the code baked
in where there was a leak from the in
from an Insider saying like yeah it was
the Ted Cruz for president the Chris
Kyle Foundation Breitbart and me one of
these things is not like the other right
but because pound for pound it was all
organic traffic we didn't have nearly
the budget and so then I call my friend
who was he was a good friend of mine uh
and he was a Harvard Law grad he's like
that's not really the law I do but
here's this guy who might this guy named
Bill Richmond half asian lawyer and then
I talked with him and he thinks like
yeah this is another conservative right
there are these wannabe Martyrs who are
like I'm being suspended or whatever it
is like well that's because you
threatened to kill someone's dog you
know whatever yeah not all but I'm
saying sometimes so uh it goes okay I'll
call you and then he calls me back he
goes wow uh yeah actually looks like
there's code in there and there's
actually quotes from The Insider and
they actually there were screenshots of
them removing us from organic trending
so we couldn't trend on Facebook
couldn't trend on Instagram uh YouTube
we've run into it and keep in mind
nothing we do is that crazy sure some of
the jokes are crazy but it's fun it's
PG-13 yeah you know what I mean it
really is for the like you're talking
about guys who are pro-second Amendment
Pro First Amendment Pro yeah pro-life
you know conservative Christians who
maybe every now and then the joke
Ruffles some feathers a little bit too
much but we've had run-ins with all of
them that's why it's you're talking
about millions of dollars just in legal
fees because we had to bake it into our
business model but I think if you're not
pushing that envelope like if like just
scratching and trying to put then it's
not fun like you know I mean it's just
boring that's part of the fun yeah not
doing it just to be vulgar or just be
like oh look what they're doing I like I
think the funniest ones are when you're
like oh [__] where it's funny and you
make them thinking you're like oh [__]
he's kind of right yeah you know what I
mean yeah especially what we're doing is
poking fun at these things that are just
so patently absurd and we're like this
can't be real life and so we'll just
kind of lean into it and they're like
well yeah it is real life and so now you
you better give me traffic to your
website you're like yeah let me tell you
what we just did which is kind of
interesting we had a uh uh we're
recruiting comedians right now so about
two months ago three months ago we made
an ad uh for comedians to apply so we
got 120 people that applied almost that
went down too a bunch of open mikers or
people Steve I'm not even joking I'm
sorry
and I we wanted you know resume this and
videos one is like literally in his
underwear naked with a gun and he just
goes [__] with me like I'm funny yeah
like what do you talk like so I got a
bunch of crap but we did 100 he got a
five-year contract with uh yeah for
different anyways so These Guys these
guys it came and you know so went from
120 to 50 to 11 people were here this
weekend they're trying out for a couple
days they were here creating we're
shooting sketches and by the way
not all stand-ups are great sketches
they can't act exactly so they're
they're at our comedy club in our Cigar
Lounge so they're kind of working
together and they're doing their own
thing oh yeah you'll see it here in a
minute so they're doing what they're
doing I'm watching these guys I'm like
okay I want to go talk to them at 11 30.
I'm sitting there talking to these guys
so tell them tell me what are you
thinking about he's you know this is
like one of the best times ever to make
fun of the president that we have
Biden's an easy one but no one's doing
it we'd like to do this Trump was good
for comedy Biden's good for comedy but
people are afraid to touch it and you
see what's going on with right now and
you know so I think there's a very major
need for entertainment in that side you
you know sometimes the right gets
criticism for not being good comedians
they're not funny you're not you're not
good at making comedy it's two or even
movies hey do we need to watch another
fireproof where the acting is like great
can you really make some movies yeah I
don't know if you saw Jesus
in the country if you were following it
or not yeah so are you gonna be making
the wings there's a massive massive
opportunity yeah massive opportunity
today well it's also because I don't
understand it so like when I talk about
community and again nothing is like
official but people can see for example
I'm not letting the cat out of the bag
on my show it's like okay you know Jim
Brewer Nick De Paula Brian like it's a
murderer Jim Norton right you have Dave
Landau that's a murderer's row of people
yeah that we have all the time where
they come on and they'll often it's like
oh this kind of this feels like filling
that Gap that was you know with tough
crowd with Colin Quinn I mean even we've
had comedians who we disagree with
entirely uh on the show on a regular
basis
um it really is like it's it's it's it's
tough because the problem is you'll get
a lot of people who say hey I'm
conservative so my friends say I'm funny
you know that's very different from like
like to me Nick depalo is the funniest
stand up who's ever lived just in my
personal opinion so when I sat down with
him and he is exactly what you expect
like he was wearing you wear these
sometimes like the kind of plaid pattern
suit and my dad uh my dad dresses like
you he's a snappy dresser he was
actually a Dean Witter and EF Hutton in
finance didn't even graduate college you
just tested off the charts got a corner
office kind of like [__] his way in
act not lying just like yeah I can do
this when's his birthday when's his
birthday 60 no what's a month
[Laughter]
hey you know uh because he's like he was
a Booker for the show we used to have
the booker well from these big shows at
NBC and they're like no one will do your
show they're terrified back in the day
because it was controversial but not the
number so my dad goes hey you know my
son just can't like he you're his
favorite comedian ever I'm so glad to
have you here and all you guys he looked
up from his phone can I can I swear yeah
one time of course okay yeah there's no
way to student Nick to follow without it
and he just looks up he goes what the
[__] do you look like the mayor of Amity
my dad is just laughing his ass off
because he's just he's just but he's
actually a super I don't want to say
sweet guy but like a good guy who you
can you can work with and trust but he's
so funny another senseless killing is my
favorite album but like Jim Brewer you
know it's unbelievable who we've had in
the show what does he do right now what
is he doing stand up yeah he does he
does his show too yeah he does a Show
online uh but he's one of the best like
you know when people talk about boxing
and stuff if you want to teach someone
how to box properly you show him Joe
Lewis exactly because it's the basics
it's done right there's no wasted
movement if you want someone to learn
how to do standard I always show them
Nick de Paulo wow and I I would say him
in like uh Patrice O'Neal because yeah
of course oh they were they had a show
together was it the Shorties watching
yeah
they were like really really good but
before we wrap up you said something
because getting a text message your food
is ready they're cooking they're they're
waiting for us
but did you see Jon Stewart today with
the holder not today three days ago
but I have my thoughts on this what was
your reaction on the way he handles like
eight minutes here's the thing Jon
Stewart is is really good yeah and uh
for example like I can look at this
objectively when Jon Stewart was on with
back then it was uh Tucker and uh was it
Chris Crossfire yeah right and then he
was on with Bill O'Reilly
look I agree with obviously talking
about I would agree with Bill O'Reilly
more it was a master class I remember uh
John started answering bill I was like
okay but Stuart you do this and you say
and uh you know people do trust you as
news and he said that may be but I don't
know if you know the lead into our show
is uh puppets making crank calls yeah
exactly and it just completely disarms
them it's like a master class but in
this there's here's the problem he's
brilliant it'll and this is the beauty
of someone who's really Adept with
comedy he sells to the audience that he
knows what he's talking about I watch it
right away and go bing bing bing because
I've been off here it's like I've been
championing at the [__] oh my God uh
where he quotes it so that's the leading
what is the leading cause of death with
kids it's not no it's not drag shows
we've done a whole segment on that you
know that number is completely fake
right where they said the leading cause
of death with kids is firearms that
includes kids 19 years old and when you
eliminate that stat of 16 to 19. it's
not even close when you eliminate the
stat of 14 to 19 and it's all intergang
related when people say hey it's the
leading cause of children you're right
it's a parent and this is the disservice
to me media does as a parent you want to
know oh is there a danger in my bathtub
should I not throw a toaster in there
when my twins are you know learning how
to how to play with the rubber duck
that's probably a bad idea not going
okay hold on a second how do we save
kids don't join a gang at 17 years old
in Memphis that's the stat that he
throws out but he's so smooth and
collected and so much experience in
dealing with adversity and I don't know
how he edits it to be fair no and I it's
the editing though Steve I could see it
cutting because the guy invited about
the speaker who's the guy he's a
congressman in uh in Oklahoma this guy
was you're talking about this is a
heavyweight versus a lightweight right
exactly when I saw the answers then kind
of he just kind of fumbled through his
response I was just like gosh there's
like five things that you can say in
response to this like do you hate women
Jon Stewart because people use their gun
to defend themselves over a million
times a year and most of those are
probably going to be women that need to
be able to have a force equalizer do you
hate women why why do you hate women
right like there's an easy way to say
this isn't as simple as you're making it
seem yeah I just had an argument that's
why we're slightly late with a Canadian
at the hotel pool I was like Joe like
this is
like people say what is it like I'm this
way I'm a little more quiet sometimes
off there because I just kind of get
tired up at the Canadian but I was at
the Canadian he was sitting there
talking he was bitching about uh all
these stops that he had to make and
checkpoints where they would stop you on
the road because he was going out to
Moncton a new uh or maybe he was going
to somewhere I don't know if he's going
to Pei or Mountain New Brunswick and he
was talking about this I'm thinking oh
this is a guy who gets it right like
like Johnny boy who's out there a friend
of mine from I've known him since I was
12 in Canada
um and then all of a sudden I realized
he starts talking about Parkland and how
America hasn't done anything and I said
well hold on a second what should they
do
and he goes well you know and Ken if you
had our laws I said you just had a man
go to uh go to prison for 10 to 20 to
life for defending his house when two
men broke into his house with guns one
was roughing up his wife likely going to
rape her and he shot this home Intruder
and he's the one who's doing time and
the Prime Minister came out and said you
do not have prime minister blackface by
the way you're like 15. I love it
we've done blackface many times in the
show as Justin Trudeau the ongoing
sketch uh and uh he said oh I don't know
about that I said yes you know about
that your prime minister said you don't
have the right you do not have the right
to defend yourself with a firearm that
to me like Gandhi said is a far greater
Act of evil in robbing a nation of
honors by the way you also don't have
freedom of speech in Canada I went
through my friend Mike Ward who had to
go all the way up to a supreme court for
a joke and a human rights tribunal it is
a subjugated conquered people in Canada
and they don't even know it and that's
the rest of the world outside of the
United States and they don't even know
they just accept it wholesale so anyways
well your question I wanted to hear what
you had to say about Jon Stewart I think
he's brilliant but I don't like what he
did here was dishonest yeah and uh but
very clever Well here here's the part
though I mean okay say John's Booker
team let's go to who John's Bookers are
Booker that they booked yeah guests
people have you mean to tell me you
didn't have 90 other people to get on
there that are bigger heavyweights than
bringing him on of course I I don't
understand
you couldn't have brought in a a Ben you
couldn't have brought in uh how many
presidents how many that's by Design but
but that to me that
um because let me tell you I watch it's
got 11 something million views can you
how many views no I'm sorry it's now at
12 and a half million views what is the
number you see there do you see a number
that's just Twitter no no that's not the
right number it's got 11 and a half
Italian views yeah yeah this thing
crushed it it went viral there's no
question about it with a whale win by
the way from YouTube and big Tech that's
a problem yeah but but if you watched it
he handled himself so well he says so
more guns equals uh more safety right
then why is it we're going up well you
can't really and the guy tried to make
the argument of it just he was not a
good debater to represent this argument
he goes he leaned and he goes when when
will it be when yeah exactly right but
nobody was a billion guns well exactly
he's like how many it's like nobody was
prepared to counter and say well
actually the stats that you're quoting
aren't accurate we've talked about that
right the take out suicides take out
gang violence and you're looking at very
low numbers relatively yeah he wasn't
ready with any of that stuff and of
course this guy was picked well he's a
paper tiger now I had to run it so one
of my who by the way I'm still friends
with a manager had to drop me back then
I don't want to say his name because
unfortunately he has to be in the closet
that he was a guy who man he was
conservative and uh he had Jon Stewart's
people reach out to him and say do you
do you have anyone else out there like
like this Stephen Craig but we don't do
conservative pundits but do you have
someone like him in other words they
were saying we like that he's young
because if they'd see me from a comedy
and maybe a reel was sent and said we
like all these things but we don't do
conservatives so if you have anyone like
him who doesn't believe his he believes
we'd love to have them wow and then when
I released that uh that was like a long
time ago like talked about it of course
they called my manager I just talked
about it they called my manager like
this guy can't be talking about what
we're doing behind the scenes you know
we're never gonna have any of your
clients again and I just remember kind
of speaking about it off the cuff but
that happened like they keep people away
by Design Stephen what's the difference
too between John Stewart and uh and Bill
Maher
hmm oh not much and here's the thing
Bill Maher now I think is going to I
don't know and I I would always say I
never questioned motivation but you know
I did go through a pre-screen with Bill
Maher's person and I'm not saying that
uh you know I would be the smartest
person on the panel far from it but
certainly if you look at some of the
people who are on there like I
definitely would hold my own uh and I
remember the pre-screen process with
Bill Maher she said what do you want to
talk about
and uh and I was like because I'm
thinking Bill Mars you know a comedian
you know by that he often like throws up
his hands like Okay and like it's like
left but uh I remember saying like well
I did just uh you know I did just uh
just read the hashtag Oscar so white and
just go to see the new live-action
Beauty and the Beast film where in 1740s
France I saw Mary J Blige be royalty
fold into a bookcase so I don't know at
what point like is what point we start
saying hey you know we're giving some
rules that don't even make sense just so
with everything's going on you want to
talk about Disney I said no I think when
you're talking about Oscar so white and
in 1740 slavery right when in that era
they would have been slaves now making
black which of course by the way just to
be clear slavery bad okay all right
slavery bad not supporting but I was
saying it's hilarious that at that point
in time it's so historically inaccurate
you're creating roles uh for for black
actors at that point that would never
even be possible and she said well what
do you think about Russia russiagate and
I said what do you mean she said what I
said what was it and I said this is
there something new
I don't know like I haven't checked the
news in the last 12 hours but so there's
been someone that's broken like evidence
late breaking she goes no she goes no
but I mean the whole situation I said
well okay do you want to talk about
Fusion GPS do you want to talk about the
steel dossier because all this is
something that was basically paid Apple
research and we know it's completely
fabricated and it's [__] I said so
you condemn me for talking about a
cultural issue at large that we know is
a sham but you want to discuss a sham
and then when I hear Bill Maher going
out saying I told him to stop talking
about Russia it's like that's what your
Booker was doing yeah yeah so I hope
that his transition is real uh I really
do I think he's probably been beaten up
by the left a little bit but then he
comes out and still says that Biden's
doing a great job and he's going to vote
for Biden I'm going well how do you how
do you come to that conclusion I don't
understand the disconnect yeah unless
you have to say it well it's the same
thing with Jon Stewart he's like it's
odd to say it's the Wu Hand Institute
right biology for the Covenant it's like
yes of course these are the same people
that you trust and now you say you still
trust why why do you still trust them
yeah I think I think you're right they
had those little moments or like God
like the real the real Soul wants to
come up but then like you said they
they're owned by somebody brother
they're surrounded by people 100 who
wouldn't allow them to say certainly oh
for sure and uh I mean he is at one
point he took it one time like he took a
pot shot at me and just like some random
podcaster or something I was like okay I
don't care but he's done jokes from our
show my mom Bill Maher has verbatim oh
wow verbatim and we know that it's been
on his radar because his Booker reached
out and so like you know it's just this
happens a lot and I don't mean like kind
of you know sort of veering into the
same topics
um I really I would love to but when he
says hey look this is a problem with the
ultra woke and the okay fine then he
says Joe Biden's done a really good job
as president and I would vote for him
is that really a net benefit
because you've gotten people to listen
to you yeah and then you've taken them
to the end game of this is what you
should do politically and I go oh God so
I don't know but the John Stewart thing
the guy is really funny
um he's very talented and that can trick
people into him sounding like he's right
a lot of what he said there was
factually inaccurate which tells me he
doesn't even do basic research because
it just takes one link deeper into the
study
either that's a good cut either that is
a terrible uh uh opposition representing
Second Amendment uh or you know he just
did a master class on asking questions
to put the pressure on the guest and
there's an art in doing that as well
yeah and he's very very good at doing
that part so uh anyways I was just
curious to know what you were going to
say about Bill Maher versus Jon Stewart
obviously the last two years you've seen
what's been happening with Bill Maher
Bill Mars now like yeah conservative I
mean Bill Maher and he's doing such a
great job and he's doing this that's
because they're clamoring right think
about that for a second they're going oh
billmar says something remotely
conservative like someone entertainment
because they're used to nothing but
talking it's also very easy to say you
know I haven't changed they've changed
that's his yeah resounding narrative
yeah which is actually true no I think
it's complete horseshit you believe I
think it's complete horseshit because
again you're talking about in 2004 uh
when it was 2000 2006 right being banned
I remember being banned from uh I think
it was uh it was it was a marianopolis
or was Concordia like getting into
trouble getting booed having to be like
escorted out of universities having
shows canceled because of things that
were Politically Incorrect back then and
at that point in time all the comedians
said ah this is just you're just making
a big deal up until not too long ago
Bill Maher was hitting those same
talking points so I do think that they
left I don't think the left left them I
do think that both the right have become
more left and the left has become
increasingly left but if you look at the
things that Bill Maher espouse uh not
too long ago
um it was left it was left it was
significantly left uh from everything
from like I think now unfortunately if
people revisiting the gay marriage topic
you know why because you have people
going hold on a second we can't put kids
on puberty blockers like that's a bridge
too far but so everyone has a line now
people realize everyone has a line and
they're going did the line have to be
back there I mean I can't tell you how
many people who used to be liberal have
said you know what I just don't know
where we stopped this and now kids are
being taken away from their parents it's
not in puberty blockers and I remember
with Dave Rubin
um you know who's a friend and he does
my show and I've done a show quite a few
times and he was very surprised back in
the day where you would say like I
didn't leave the left left me Stephen
you know that kind of thing and uh he
said like I know like you're more you're
more libertarian like you support
same-sex marriage I said no I don't
because he was surprised because when I
see him I give him a big hug you know I
see him I I have a lot of love for the
guy and I think a lot of people think
that if you have an issue politically
with the blurring of gender lines it
means you hate people and I said no
here's the deal and I don't think it's a
fair comparison to interracial marriage
because I think that uh fundamentally
black and white people as parents are
interchangeable if they want to be
present in their children's lives in
other words I do not think that a black
woman is incapable of providing to a
child whom she loves what a white woman
can as a mother I said but I don't think
that two dads can provide what a mother
and father can and I don't think that
two moms can provide what a mother and a
father can I don't think that men and
women are interchangeable as parents as
we could argue people of different races
and I think you're not going to like
where this ends up because to say
they're interchangeable is to say that
uh you know the gender issue that the
gender lines don't exist and that's not
a gay thing that's going into whole new
territory we're talking about that maybe
in 2016 2015 2017. with Ruben with
Reuben it was surprised and he was
surprised he said okay and I said now
look and you have to understand why
marriage laws exist I wish the
government wasn't in the the marriage
business at all but the reason why was
because before federal government for
state government for they wanted
self-governance and they realized a
nuclear family was the most important
way to do that that's why you have tax
incentives that's why you have the
government recognizing mom and dad and
that's not the same with
Two Dads two moms I think you should
have civil unions all the same rights
but I said this is a slippery slope and
I think that saying men and women are
fundamentally interchangeable will
Target that fabric of society and uh I
don't know who's pushing for that one we
should all be agreeing on the civil
union where do those conversations end
with Reuben
but I think they're surprised because I
think you have to be like a westbro
Baptist Church person if you go well
there are issues with the same-sex
marriage thing and the beauty is that
you can have your opinion that's what
people always think like he's right no
you could have your opinion you have
your opinion you stick by it that you
and Jake ever do anything together or no
oh god well technically technically I
crashed my Southwest panel uh of
jankweiger as jankweiger yeah yeah so I
showed up and I was like yeah I'm the
real Jack uighur and uh and the reason
the reason I did this impression was
because they would pick on me when I was
this tiny YouTube channel right and then
once I grew big enough I was like well
let's do a debate you know because they
would pick on me they said no and they
all of a sudden I was like Voldemort
they wouldn't acknowledge my name so I
started what I would do is I would do
these young Turks parodies where I would
do impressions of them and then uh I
would actually like run them back then
as ads before Young Turks videos
and they got really pissed he's watching
you as him yeah it's the most
embarrassed I've ever been in my life
but I just felt like I had to do it is
that him right there yeah yeah and
gained a ton of weight for the uh or you
put a Pros yeah
look how uncomfortable he is is that
okay
um
[Music]
they had it in the wrong place so we had
him in the wrong I went to the wrong
Marriott he's dressed in full checkout
that he comes out and there's like no
Ballroom b or whatever
Bill Nye yeah I was in the wrong
Courtyard match had to get one of those
golf court golf cart yeah look there's
nobody even in there I know I know that
is so funny I felt I didn't want to do
it I felt compelled to do it but your
nerves must be buried alive I've never
been so nervous in my life so you guys
have never done anything together never
other than that no what sure you
wouldn't would you talk to him would you
have a conversation well again there's a
big difference between saying I disagree
and like calling me a Nazi you know
you're saying he's a garbage and he's a
horrible person and also like
misrepresenting you know what a big
thing is is they had um they missed they
said uh Stephen calls women you know
lying [__] and he's sexist and and
they even break this rule whenever we
tell a joke on air like Joe what do I
say if we tell a joke that we know is
going to get some heat always make sure
that there's I said like 30 seconds
before 30 seconds the people have
context yeah yeah because people will go
and they'll afford you that right
they'll look at the context say it was a
joke and I think this was a joke with
Christine blasey Ford remember uh yeah
which we now all know is fake yes 100
and uh the joke in one of the monologues
was um something like of course
Christine blasey Ford uh authorities are
investigating and uh they're trying to
make sense of I don't remember exactly
the setup right verbatim but the story
which she the account that she gave to
the Washington Times which was different
from the account that she gave to her
therapist which was different from the
account that she provided to the
authorities of course uh they are still
open to the possibility that she's a
lying [__]
that's still on the table yeah and they
said like Stephen calls women lying
there we go right there yes sir no no
just a woman exactly specific instance
okay and so when they do that like you
know they're being dishonest big time
and but yeah I would but I was sitting I
was like I still think it's a funny joke
I think it's hilarious but it looks
crazy but look at the power of people
just reading that that didn't know what
you said you're automatically that guy
yeah it was the police yeah by the way
here's what's crazy the reason why I
asked that we had Jank here I don't know
six months ago what was the time 10
months ago eight months ago no I think
it's about a year March really yeah
and I gotta tell you
it's very interesting I had no idea what
to expect when he came in I don't know
what direction was going to go we had a
very good conversation together and he
made his argument you know I made mine I
asked the questions you know he went
back and obviously you know politically
where he lies yeah and then we had the
uh Kyle kulinski on uh four months ago
five months ago two months two months
ago great conversation we had this David
packman on young guy fiery you know
energized and you know he very good uh
and then who else have we had on we had
a bunch of these guys on just to kind of
see because we had plenty of liberals on
the way on the show they wouldn't do it
for long and I understand that yeah I
totally understand Roland Martin here
yeah we had Rolo Martin here and it was
fireworks it was crazy we had uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson but that wasn't even like
a I just asked a question about covet
and that one will hold this One
Direction with the conversation but but
you know what it is like I again who's
your customer who are you doing it for
to me it's two things one do you like
doing it I do I like talking to people
and seeing where it goes two who's the
customer the viewer listening and saying
you know what Pat you were wrong there
okay let me go do a little more research
and you know what that argument he has a
better argument than you okay cool or
you know what I don't know I don't know
if I agree with Kyle or Pac-Man great
make up your mind and then my argument
your argument gets better the audience
is winning yeah you know we're building
that relationship to say okay dude in
these three places we're way off because
I asked a question from uh David Pacman
who would consider himself well I don't
know politically what he would put
himself left taxes how much taxes is too
much taxes right and you go I don't know
30 and we were kind of on the same page
when it came down to taxes the most you
pay 30 percent of camels like man flat
tax is a little bit better for me I had
the conversation with Jerry Springer and
Jerry Springer's like I'm like Jerry how
much taxes would you be willing to pay
I don't know what kind of a question
this is that's the question to me
politically yeah here's your budget go
spend it and stay tight and stop asking
me for more if you don't know how to
spend the money that I gave you that's
now 32 trillion dollars I don't know I
paid 90 in taxes I said you would pay 90
tax we're taller you pay 90 taxes I'm
like if you're like saying you pay 90
taxes why did you move your show from
where it was to Connecticut she's saving
the taxes you did this why did you do
why haven't you done it already yeah the
IRS will take your check and by the way
you know you know you know what's the
last question I asked uh Jerry asked
Jerry don't think about the Jerry today
that's worth 50. yeah think about the
Jerry that was making 50k a year coming
up would you be okay paying that taxes I
mean the perspective is you're taking
that fire away from the younger guy and
then that's when the conversation was
like I can't believe you're saying this
I'm not like I just enjoy having a
conversation with opposition I think I
think opposition brings leaks in our
arguments strength lengthens your
argument and then audience
we couldn't get people on the left to
really come on the show a whole lot and
it's not a debate though it was always
designed to be the Socratic method like
when we do debates we do debates uh on
the show I even debate uh right-wing
people like like Ben Shapiro Jordan
Peterson John style so all them I just
uh there's this character Skyler Chardon
it's called Devil's Advocate and I
always tell them like don't think you're
talking to Stephen Crowder like just no
it's not gonna be like I'm a liberal I'm
stupid which a lot of conservatives do
this character of people on the left
going to print yeah exactly I'm going to
present the strongest arguments possible
and sometimes they've been tripped up
and there's some funny stuff like we
always every time they're talking like I
throw them off I'll be smoking a bigger
Vape is that a segment yeah Devil's
Advocate yeah and we ended up with
problems because then conservatives like
this one's pretty tough because it's
like again I'm like
arguments because it's for the audience
for them to be and it was really they
never used clips against you like did
the left use clip saying this is what
Crowder said or no no no no no okay I'm
dressed up in an outfit with tattoos in
a coexistence
um
but
that but all you know what my prep was
my prep for that was the mirror image of
Change My Mind
so I would go let me because I always go
claim truth flame truth what I most had
what I anticipate to be the most likely
claims and change my mind is not a
debate it's meant to be the Socratic
method to encourage people to ask why
and the irony is that a lot of people
end up changing their minds but when we
do that I'll you know we'll sit down for
three four hours and it's just anyone
who comes down well that professors come
down sometimes we've had reporters and
people from television sit down
um and it's not just students but that
is exhausting yeah four hours our
biggest goal is not to tell people what
to think it's to teach people how to
think like go through this process and
make sure that you're not making the
mistake of being able to point these
things out like some of these guys we
just talked about Bill Maher and those
guys and still making the mistake of
thinking that's the party to trust
because there's something that's broken
in the way that you think about these
things critically and go oh my gosh I
don't trust them for this this or this
but I still am going to vote for him
like wait a minute how did you get back
over here yeah right so it's not just
changed my mind it's hey we're quoting
to you people on the left all of our
sources like if any of our researchers
people come to us with a source from Fox
News we throw it out immediately not
because we don't have Fox but because
it's like yeah we understand the talking
point we want to know what they are
saying so that we can tell our audience
here's what they're saying here's why
it's wrong think through this process go
to our website don't believe me go to
the website click on the link see what
the article says we're not making it up
and we always try and go if it's like if
it's a study we'll actually link to the
you know study that's there yeah or if
it's like a new poll we'll link directly
to rasby Center for the only time we'll
ever use a conservative source is if
it's an exclusively like conservative
story that they have a scoop on
um so most health sources are leftists
like New York Times Washington Post and
we provide 30 to 60 every single day
when we do the shows yeah every day
respect I genuinely think that you
really like just never met you before
I've seen your your stuff I know what's
happening but like just from talking
with both of you like when it comes to
like fans I could tell that you guys
really give a [__] about what you're
doing of what you're saying and like
that that that I think resonates and
that's why you guys have such the
following that is going to follow you
and stay with you guys and stay loyal
well once again appreciate you for
coming out this was fantastic
congratulations to you guys March 20 yet
yes 20th March time he Yeah March 20th
it's the same same bad times
put the link below again March 20th
Stephen Crowder back with a lot of
specials the last 90 days they've not
been sitting around they've been
producing stuff uh you know I know the
world's excited for you guys to be doing
that and then also at the same time we
are doing our next live podcast the
weekend of the UFC in Miami which is the
fights the eighth Saturday April 7th at
night first time we're doing a podcast
Friday night seven to nine and we will
be having tickets go for so probably
sometime this week last time it sold out
I think in like three hours and
um the moment we send a text out it's
not going to be Public Announcement it's
purely sells out once you send a text if
you do want to be on the list of the
last podcast we have 200 people in the
house some guys went into the Cigar
Lounge afterwards we had a great time
together this one's gonna be seven and
nine so probably people are going to
stay at the club till late night drinks
all that other stuff so uh text award
podcast
to
310-340-1132 once again text award
podcast three one zero three four zero
one one three two to be part of that
list the moment we announce tickets
you'll be the first to get the text to
purchase a ticket so we can see you
April 7th Friday 7-9 at the studio with
VT with myself and our crew having said
that once again link to podcast show
with uh uh Stephen coming back will be
below uh to get signed up for that again
put in your account on the March 20th
Stephen thanks for coming out this was a
blast man I really enjoyed it I truly
really enjoyed it you guys have a nice
set up here very subtle hey the lights
we just went live take care everybody